l' arrivé je je propose de débuter cette
cette audition de notre commission
d'enquête je
remercie
monsieurs bar bar bar bar et les
personnes qui qui les accompagnent je
merci d'avoir répondu à notre
sollicitation mes chers collègues je
salue également donc on poursuit
aujourd'hui les les travaux de de notre
commission d'enquête avec l'audition de
Monsieur bar qui est délégué
interministériel au nouveau nucléaire
c'est ça et Monsieur Xavier hursa
directeur exécutif en charge de la
direction ingénierie et projet nouveau
nucléaair et et de la direction
innovation responsabilité d'entreprise
et stratégie d'électricité de France
c'est bien
ça alors il me il m'choit de de vous
demander demander de de prêter serement
conformément au aux règles euh de
fonctionnement des commissions d'enquête
parlementa donc avant de vous donner la
la parole je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête est possible des des peines
prévu aux articles 434- 13 14 et 15 du
code pénal et je vous invite à à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le jure monsieurursa
monsieur
bar je vous remercie par ailleurs le cas
échéant de nous faire part de vos
éventuels liens d'intérêt s'il y en a
vous vous me direz je pense que c'est
pas le cas voilà la la le Sénat a
constitué le le 18 janvier dernier une
commission d'enquête sur la production
la consommation le prix de l'électricité
aux horizons 2035 et
2050 nos travaux sont centré sur le
présent et et l'avenir du système
électrique est-il en capacité de faire
face à la demande d'offrir au
particulier à nos entreprises une
électricité en prix raisonnable et
quelles sont ses perspectives de de
développement voilà le le le le sujet
central euh l'objet de la Table Ronde
d'aujourd'hui est important parce qu'il
nous faut apprécier l'avenir de notre
parc nucléaire à cet horizon 2030 2050
un consensus semble se dessiner sur la
nécessité pour décarboner massiv dem
d'utiliser l'énergie
nucléaire mais voilà quel est
aujourd'hui le contenu du programme de
relance de
l'électroncléire est-ce que c'est 6 pr
14 PR2 d'avantage quel est le bon niveau
auquel nous devons placer le le curseur
selon vous comment aboutir à des coûts
d'électricité satisfaisants maîtrisés
pour les particuliers mais aussi pour
notre industrie ce qui siifie comment
aboutir à une construction des pr à un
cooupt maîtrisé alors que nous avons t
tous en tête les déboires d'okiluoto
d'Inle point et et de flamandville
comment
faire la soudure si on emplo ce motl
avec 2035 puisque la la production de
ces nouveaux pr pourrait débuter à ce
moment-l peut-être au mieux d'ailleurs
alors que celle du parc historique va
décliner ou va
déclinant voilà les quelques thèmes on
en abordera d'autres sur lesquels notre
rapporteur va vous interroger je vais
lui laisser la parole nous vous
proposons de de dérouler cette audition
en quatre temps euh nous allons vous
vous laisser 10 minutes pour présenter
votre votre travail et votre réflexion
de manière préliminaire et euh ensuite
donc on aura un temps de de
questions-réponsse en particulier avec
notre rapporteur Vincent de de lae puis
avec les autres membres de la commission
ici présent et vous pourrez
éventuellement revenir sur les propos
voilà des des des des des autres
participants euh on va faire ça de
manière la plus interactive et agréable
et réactive possible voilà et on on
terminera par une dernière batterie de
de de questions réponse je vous demande
simplement donc exposé liiminaire 10 10
minutes après dans les réponses aux
questions de pas être trop long le plus
concis possible pour que voilà on puisse
poser le plus de questions possibles et
que que l'échange soit soit le plus est
le plus le plus agréable et le plus
approfondi possible voilà merci je donne
la parole à Monsieur
bar pardon à monsieur le rapporteur
excuse-moi non non excusez-moi non mais
enfin bon exc monsieurpp mer monsieur le
Président juste juste quelques quelques
éléments mais le président a bien
expliqué l'objet de notre commission
donc c'est notre commission d'enquête
c'est pas elle est tournée vers
l'avenir la commission de l'Assemblée
nationale a fait un point sur l'énergie
en général sur les 30 30 40 dernières
années euh nous notre souhait c'est
plutôt de se projeter dans l'avenir à la
fois sur le plan de la consommation
puisque la consommation détermine quand
même une en partie les la nécessité de
de produire l'électricité donc les les
perspectives de
consommation quel type de mix
énergétique et production on a en face
euh par rapport au renouvelabl euh et
aussi à l'intermittence au pilotable bon
tout cela on a en réflexion et puis bien
sûr on a une partie sur le le prix sur
la façon dont on peut avoir un prix qui
soit moins volatile et plus en rapport
sans doute avec le coût de production de
de notre électricité donc là nous avons
déjà eu des tables rondes sur notamment
le le nucléaire entre guillemets
historique euh et euh donc avec avec des
perspectives aussi d'avenir puisque
puisqueil y avait il y a les questions
de de prolongation éventuelle de ce
nucléire historique jusqu'à 60 ans voire
80 ans donc les conditions tout cela bon
c'est je sais pas si dans votre propos
vous souhaitez le y revenir ou pas euh
en tout cas bon moi moi j'auris j'aurais
forcément des questions mais ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de se dire quel quel
programme on est capable de de mener
dans quelles conditions à quelle à
quelle échéance et à quel coût parce que
c'est aussi important qu'on ait ce coût
une évaluation du coût de production
pour pour pouvoir comparer les
différentes énergies aussi voilà c'est
des éléments que dont on a on a
besoin d'avoir voilà je je dis ça aussi
pour
EDF parce que on a eu je crois que
c'était avanthier
euh on n pas eu de réponse en tout cas
sur le le coût le
coût économique complet euh donc ça
c'est c'est des choses qui qui nous
intéressent aussi voilà donc euh
monsieur le Président je vous REP passe
la parole monsieur bar vous avez la
parole
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs bah écoutez je
vous dirai quelques mots d'abord si vous
me permettez une introduction puisque la
la Délégation interministérielle au
nouveau nucléaire que j'ai l'honneur de
diriger est une nouvelle administration
qui a été créé donc en en en novembre
2022 euh par un décret de la première
ministre et avec pour mission pour
mission de superviser le programme du
nouveau nucléaire français dont nous
allons parler évidemment pendant toute
la la séance supervision des travaux
industriels qui sont évidemment menés
par EDF qui EDF qui est à la fois le le
maître d'ouvrage le maître d'œvre et
l'exploitant de ces de ces nouveaux
récteurs dont nous avons parlé et nous
avons également pour mission évidemment
de coordonner l'ensemble des
administrations de les mobiliser
l'ensemble des administrations qui sont
parties prenantes de d'un tel programme
qu'elle soit à à à Bercy ou ou ou
ailleurs merci pour l'essentiel
désormais avec le la mise en place de
des des responsabilités de l'énergie au
ministère de l'Économie des Finances
bref au ministère de de Bercy donc voilà
quelle est notre mission nous sommes une
petite équipe hein de de de H8 personnes
aujourd'hui nous nous sommes cadrés par
le décret de création à 15 personnes et
et voilà donc notre mission et voilà ce
ce ce dont ce dont je vais maintenant
vous vous entretenir si vous le
permettez bien entendu nous sommes aussi
en relation avec tous les acteurs
institutionnel autre que autre que
l'industrie et que les administrations
que je viens de citer je pense à
l'autorité de sureté nucléaire ou la
future autorité
indépendante je je vais me tromper dans
le sigle airsnn
ou j'étais sûr que j'allais me tromper
j'étais sûr que j'allais me tromper bon
et et donc saluons d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour saluer le débat qui a eu
lieu hier soir ou cette nuit même je
crois puisquil s'est terminé cette nuit
sur ce sujet mais peut-être que nous y
reviendrons
euh donc je passe je pense à l'autorité
de nucléaire je pense au CEA évidemment
Commissariat à l'énergie atomique est un
acteur un acteur éminent de du domaine
nucléaire alors
notre périmètre en ce qui concerne donc
la Délégation interministérielle
consiste à superviser le programme
industriel du nouveau nucléaire France
c'est-à-dire le programme
comprenant les réacteurs PR2 don dont je
vais maintenant parler plus en détail
sur lequel nous reviendrons avec Zav
j'imagine pendant tout le long de la
séance et puis nous nous préoccupons
également du du projet EDF de de small
mod qui s'appelle newward donc vous avez
sans doute entendu parler déjà pourquoi
parce que ces deux projets sont des
projets de technologie d de 3e
génération alors on dit parfis 3 génra
plus ça fait plus ça fait plus riche
plus chque enfin bref de 3è génération
c'està-dire du type de génération des
CPR dont vous avez parler tout à l'heure
monsieur le monsieur le Président
actuellement qui viennent d'entrer en
service ou qui sont en estance d'entrer
en service donc voilà quel est notre
périmètre et cette donc ce double
périmètre donc PR2 et SMR nard c'est
deux des chantiers majeurs de qui
contribuent ou qui font partie du
programme de relance nucléaire voulu par
le Président de la République et annoncé
donc dans son discours de Belfort de de
2022 etvolu donc par le gouvernement qui
comprend également vous l'avez évoqué
également monsieur le monsieur le
Président tout à l'heure bah évidemment
la restauration du productible de DF
directeur actuellement en service la
prolongation de leur durée de vie j'y
reviendrai dans un instant quand on
parlera de la de la relation à faire
avec l'arrivée des EP2 et et puis
évidemment le le développement de
nouvelles filières vous avez entendu
parler des des modul réacteur et autes
advance modul acteurs qui qui sont sous
Tup dans le cadre de de France
2030 qui sont déjà en cours et puis un
dernier point que sur lequel il faut pas
il faudra il faudra pas oublier c'est
évidemment le le renouvellement des
installations du cycle de combustible en
amont les usines d'arréchissement ça je
dirais c'est parti he l'usine George BES
2 Orano est investi
dedans naval il faut y travailler pour
effectivement prendre la suite des
installations actuellement à la et
ailleurs à l'horizon 2040 donc notre
périmètre c'est le PR2 plus narde dans
cet ensemble de relance du programme
nucléaire qui lui-même fait partie de la
stratégie française donc pour l'énergie
et et le climat donc le avec l'objectif
avec l'objectif évidemment de se
débarrasser des industries fossiles à
l'horizon 2050 au plus tard je signale
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui que nous sommes
déjà les derniers chiffres de RTE l'ont
encore dit hier soir à 90 92 % très
exactement de de d' d'électricité
décarbonée en France 92 %. bon j'ai
tendance à dire qu'il dit mieux hein je
pense pas d'ailleurs que personne puisse
dire
mieux donc les quatre piliers de la
stratégie française de l'énergie et le
climat au-delà donc de cette relance
ducléaire que je viens de de brièvement
résumer c'est évidemment la soriété
énergétique RTE encore Sion veut il a
sorti hier le bilan 2023 a montrer
qu'effectivement la la la trajectoire de
l'électricité était légèrement à la
baisse sur le sous le coup de ces
mesures de sobriété l'efficacité
énergétique donc des processus
industriels qui soi de moins en moins
consommateur d'énergie et surtout qui
consomme de l'électricité décarboné je
me souviens au mois de il y a quelques
jours de cela nous étions à à dunkererk
avec les ministr les ministres le maire
et Béchu pour
inaugurer un nouvel investissement
d'arcelormital dans l'aririe dekerer
pour arriver à décarboner donc le
processus qu'il utilise évidemment pour
produire des acierss et puis bien
entendu l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables moi je considère pour ma
part et c'est un débat je suppose que
vous aurez à l'intérieur de votre
commission que évidemment il faut sortir
de cette opposition parfois entre les
énergies renouvelables et l'énergie
nucléaire et que les deux sont
évidemment parfaitement complémentaires
à quel niveau de productible de terraw
par an effectivement ça c'est toute la
question qu'on va pouvoir creuser dans
je suppose dans les dans les dans les
instants qui viennent alors pourquoi
pourquoi le programme PR2 c'est ça la
première question que je vous propose
d'essayer de répondre rapidement
pourquoi le programme PR2 ben parce que
vous l'avez évoqué monsieur le Président
dans votre propos introductif nos
réacteurs actuellement en service ils
ont tous été mis en service dans une
période d'une quinzaine d'années donc à
la fin du siècle sicle précédent et donc
ils vont arriver un jour ou l'autre
quand même en fin de vie alors certes
évidemment
EDF cherche à les prolonger vous avez 10
60 ans on va chercher à aller plus loin
reparlera peut-être plus en détail il
n'empêche que un jour il seront pas
éternel et on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui
si vous voulez par exemple si on fait je
vous donnerai simplement un exemple si
on fait l'hypothèse que l'on prolonge
tous les réacteurs actuellement en
service à 60 ans ce qui est un objectif
mais qui n'est pas encore acté àquis et
bien nous aurons nous aurons à partir de
2039 2040 en moyenne une perte de
puissance installée de 4 Gow par an je
répète en faisant l'hypothèse de 60 ans
pour l'ensemble des réacteurs
actuellement en service alors certes
nous irons nous chercheronsf vous le
dire aller plus loin par rapport à ces
60 ans peut-être 70 80 et cetera comme
les américains qui ont déjà réussi à
afficher ces 80 ans mais n'empêche que
on aura bien à remplacer ces ces
réacteurs actuellement en service qui je
vous rappelle représente une puissance
installée euh de l'ordre de supérieur à
60 GW supérieur à partir du moment où on
aura mis en service plan mobile dans le
courant de cette année alors face à ce
défi qu'on appelle parfois dans notre
jargon l'effet falaise c'estàdire le
fait qu'à partir de l'horizon 2040 donc
la puissance installée des réacteurs en
service va décroître de manière
rapide nous aurons donc besoin de les
renouveler alors nous avons nous avons
suivi donc la proposition de DF qui date
de
2021 20 21 qui consiste à faire ce qu'on
appelle un PR2 le PR2 c'est quoi c'est
une version optimisée industrialisée de
l'pr quand je dis le Pr c'est vous les
avez cité le Pr de flamville le Pr
deokuto le Pr de Taishan en Chine et le
Pr dehpc INP par alors version optimisée
industrialisée ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire un réacteur nucléaire qui reprend
les atout de l' pr atout en terme de
puissance installée 1,6 GW à tout en
terme de performance de sûreté en
particulier évidemment prise en compte
des enseignements des incidents des
accidents qui ont eu lieu dans les
décennies précédente je pense en
particulier à Fukushima en 2011
et un un PR qui un PR2 qui doit être
adapté quand même à l'horizon à
l'horizon de la fin du siècle puisque si
on les met en service à partir de 2040 à
l'horizon 2040 un peu avant 2040 ça veut
dire qu'ils pourront vivre au moins
jusqu'en 20000 donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut prendre des hypothèses de durée de
vie de ces PR2 jusqu'à l'horizon 200 ça
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire par
exemple prendre des hypothèses
d'évolution climatique à l'horizon 200
ce qui est évidemment vous en doutez un
un défi deuxème adaptation à faire qu'il
faut que je me permets de signaler c'est
le fait qu'effectivement ces PR2 devront
fonctionner dans un réseau électrique
dans lequel il y aura de plus en plus
d'énergie renouvelable éolien solaire
qui vous le savez sont des énergies
intermittentes ce qui suppose pour
réaliser l'adaptation à ce réseau de
rendre notre PR2 effectivement modulable
ou ou manœuvrable suivant suivant
l'expression que l'on emploie donc ça
c'est l'objectif en terme de performance
alors ensuite comment il faut le faire
et bien je DIRIS il faut pas le faire
comme les précédents les précédents que
j'ai cité tout à l'heure
taan par ordre d'entrée en piste si je
peux dire taan nouto
flamville HPC enfin j'espère
euh c'était des prototypes ce sont des
prototypes c'est-à-dire réaliser à
l'unité un par un voire par paire à HPC
ce qui est quand même une excellente
chose parce que ça va nous roder pour
cette réaction par paire réalisation par
paire mais ce sont des prototypes
désormais ce qu'il faut faire c'est un
PR2 qui sera capable en série une fois
qu'il sera qu'il aura atteint le stade
de la maturité de série de remplacer les
réacteurs en série des réacteurs en
service pardon dont je viens de parler
parce que vous avez dit combien
faudra-t-il on est parti sur une tranche
de 6 première tranche de 6 ça c'est pour
effectivement permettre d'aboutir à un
premier modèle de série aussi compétitif
que possible en terme de coût et dél
derrière nous travaillons déjà sur une
extension à 8 c'était déjà dans le
discours du du président Macron de 2000
2022 mais s'il faut aller jus tout va
dépendre de la de la puissance installée
qu'il va falloir renouveler et donc du
productible qu'on attend qu'on attend de
ces réacteur à l'horizon à l'horizon
post 2040 c'estàd 2040 à 2100
aujourd'hui nos réacteurs nos 60 GW
installés ils sont capables de générer
on va dire on est à 320 en
2023 on va monter à 400 terwh d'ici
d'ici quelques années d'ici 2030 disons
bon combien faudra-t-il quel est le
productible qui sera nécessaire à
l'horizon 2050 puis 200 aujourd'hui
effectivement faut faire tous les
exercices de de programmation plurénelle
de l'énergie qui sont en cours ils ont
pas encore ils ont pas encore
définitivement abouti mais on peut quand
même se dire que il faut viser plusieurs
centaines de terrawteurs de productible
et plusieurs centaines de terrawteur de
productive ça veut dire peut-être pas 60
GW de puissance installée comme
aujourd'hui mais ça faut dire plusieurs
dizaines de gigw or chaque PR2 c'est 1,6
GW je le répète donc combien faudra-t-il
de de de PR2 je sais pas SIAV ça le sais
aujourd'hui moi je ne le sais pas encore
mais je sais dire que ce sera
significatif et que sans doute même les
8 + 6 c'estàd les 6 + 8 pardon ne
suffiront pas ne suffiront pas j'en suis
j'en suis personnellement intimement
convaincu donc pour faire ça ça veut
dire qu'il faut arriver à un modèle de
PR2 de série qui soit encore une fois
compétitif en terme de coût et de coût
et de délai de réalisation vous l'avez
dit Monsieur monsieur le rapporteur
c'est ça qui est important et c'est bien
l'objectif que nous nous sommes donnés
alors comment comment y arriver comment
EDF a-t-il pris si je peux dire cette ce
défi en main avec un certain nombre de
de Levi d'industrialisation en fait il
faut passer le défi de le PR2 par
rapport à le Pr c'est de faire un
programme industriel un programme
industrialisé qui soit encore une fois
un programme de série pas un programme
de prototype ça veut dire qu'il faut
simplifier le design la définition de C
opères alors simplifier le design ça
veut dire simplifier le génie civil ça
veut dire simplifier les exigences on
pourra Xavier moi-même vous donner des
exemples tout à l'heure si vous le
souhaitez d'ors et déjà des hypothèses
entreprises dans ce domaine donc il faut
simplifier il faut
faciliter la construction la
constructibilité de ces de ces réacteurs
parce que c'est ça qui a essentiellement
pêché dans les réacteur prototype dont
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure pour ça il
faut standardiser le nombre le type et
le nombre d'équipement que l'on utilise
sur un sur sur un un PR il faut faire
appel à de plus en plus de
préfabrication parce que c'est quand
même plus facile entre guillemets ou
moins difficile plutôt de fabriquer une
usine que fabriquer sur un chantier sur
HPC aujourd'hui il y a combien 11000
11000 11000 personnes à peu près vous
imaginez un chantier un chantier de
d'une paire de pair c'est 11000
personnes qui travaillent en même temps
là-dessus bah quand on voit ça on peut
comprendre les difficultés quand même
qui ont été rencontré et qui sont encore
rencontrés je moi moi qui a fait un
certain nombre de programmes dans
d'autres autre domaine dans le passé je
suis parfaitement compréhensible
vis-à-vis de ça c'est une difficulté qui
n'est pas évidente à laquelle il faut
faire face il faut évidemment aussi que
l'ensemble de la filière nucléaire se
remette en remonte en compétence et en
capacité parce que la filière évidemment
de nos entreprises dans le nucléaire
français bien elles ont vécu elles ont
vécu quelques années quelques même deux
ou trois décennies on peut le dire
clairement de trois décennies de
sous-charge donc évidemment c'est pas
comme ça que l'on garde que l'on
maintient les compétences donc ces
compétences il faut les il faut les
retrouver et c'est le le le le défi qui
qui nous attend donc c'est un défi c'est
un défi pour EDF bien entendu qui est le
qui est le leader qui encore une fois
qui est le maître d'orage le maître d'œv
l'exploitant mais c'est un défi pour
toute la filière et nous avons en
particulier en place grâce à EDF et
grâce à une une ces émanations je le mot
émanation même si c'est pas forcément le
mot l'Université des métiers nucléire
qui est justement là
pour développer un plan d'action visant
à la attractivité à la formation et à
l'intégration de l'ensemble des salariés
qui vont être nécessaires dans les
prochaines années pour garantir cette
remontée en puissance vous connaissez
peut-être déjà le chiffre he vous savez
que les les le gifen donc l'association
des industries nucléaires a a chiffré à
100000 recrutement le nombre de
recrutements nécessaires sur les 10
années qui viennent c'estàdire 10000 par
an tout niveau confondu depuis le depuis
le le compagnon jusqu'à jusqu'à
l'ingénieur donc c'est un défi quand
même très très significatif aujourd'hui
l'industrie nucléaire c'est de 100000
personnes ou 220000 sur les chipes ENF
c'est grandur donc voyez ça veut dire
qu'il faut il faut recruter la moitié
l'équivalent la moitié de ce qui existe
aujourd'hui sur les 10 années qui
viennent dans un contexte qui est celui
où la France veut se réindustrialiser
donc ça veut dire que les compagnons
comme les techniciens comme les
ingénieurs ils onuront le choix ils nont
pas forcément dans le nucléaire il
pouront aller dans l'aéronautique dans
le spatial dans la défense BF dans tous
les secteurs qui font l'objet à la fois
d'une relance et d'une
réindustrialisation donc ça c'est très
important et c'est effectivement un défi
essentiel pour pour l'ensemble de notre
de notre programme alors où en
sommes-nous aujourd'hui et et je je
conclurai peut-être là-dessus avant de
pour vous laisser la parole où en
sommes-nous aujourd'hui et bien écoutez
nous sommes au stade de de la définition
du programme nous sommes en train de
passer comment on dit dans le jargon
dans notre jargon qui est un peu je
reconnais un peu technocratique voilà
merci jeais pas le direavant parce que
c'est pas moi qui l'ai inventé CEF ah
c'est vrai mais j'aurais pas fait mieux
rassure-toi j'aurais pas fait mieux donc
on passe du basicque au detail design
donc ça demande effectivement la
vérification de la maturité de ce design
donc de cette conception on va dire si
on traduitad c'est ma conception
maturité de cette de cette définition
et donc nous en sommes là nous avons
d'ailleurs engagé sur ce sur ce jalon
une revue de programme au début de
l'année 2023 celle-ci a déposé des
premières conclusions à la fin de
l'année 2023 nous avons décidé avec avec
EDF de la prolonger en 2024 et donc
c'est tout l'exercice qui est
actuellement en cours pour aboutir
encore une fois à ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure cé être capable de lancer ces
6pr2 par une première tranche de panli
avec donc une paire de de réacteurs qui
sera la tête de série panli ça sera une
nouvelle tête de série par rapport à ce
que nous avons déjà réalisé mais il
faudra que derrière le plus rapidement
possible euh dès les dès les paires
suivantes des Gravelines puis buget plus
puis la suite quand on aura décidé des
plus V il faudra aboutir à une une
réalisation en série encore une fois qui
soit compétitive en terme du du coût de
de l'électricité comme vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le rapporteur tout à
l'heure alors en pratique quand même en
2024 il va se passer une chose
importante c'est que nous allons pouvoir
lancer les travaux préparatoires du site
de panli travaux préparatoires donc qui
sont des travaux de génie civil
aménagement de la plateforme dérctage de
la falaise extension de la plateforme
marine et cetera tout ça ça sera
normalement permis dès le 1er juillet
2024 dès le 1er juillet de cette année
grâce à l'autorisation environnementale
et grâce au projet de loi d'accélération
des processus des procédures nucléaires
pardon qui a été adopté que vous avez
adopté je vous en remercie en juin
dernier qui permet effectivement de
démarrer les travaux préparatoires sans
attendre l'autorisation de création qui
elle conditionne le lancement des
travaux sur les installations nucléaair
proprement dit voilà monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur ce que
je voulais vous dire brièvement à en
guise introduction merci Monsieur B je
donne la parole à Monsieur hursa
oui merci monsieur le Président minut on
va essayer pardon j viens 10 minutes
mais bon allez-y d'accord merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
Messieurs les les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs c'est un grand plaisir pour
moi d'être avec vous cet après-midi pour
échanger sur en effet l'avenir de notre
mix électrique ces conditions
industrielles et en particulier sur les
sur les sujets nucléaires qui sont des
sujets qui nous qui nous passionnent et
et engagent les équipes de DF tous les
jours nous sommes en effet comme comme
Joel bar vient de de l'expliquer à un
moment tout à fait
charnière un moment où la la France
s'engage à une décarbonation de son
économie d'ici d'ici 2050 ce qui
signifie en fait une transformation très
profonde de son système énergétique
aujourd'hui l'énergie consommée en
France provient à peu près des 2/3 de
sources fossiles sur toutes ces formes
pétrole pétrole
charbon gaz et l'électricité représente
à peu près 25 % de la consommation en
énergie finale c'est d'ailleurs un petit
peu plus que dans certains autres pays
puisqu'on a déjà une part de chauffage
électrique chez nous quand d'autres pays
qui ont fait moins le choix de
l'électricité sont plutôt à 20 ou 22 %
de part d'électricité dans leur énergie
en 2050 il faudra que cette part de 25 %
soit devenu au moins 50 % si on veut
atteindre la neutralité carbone pour la
France il faudra bien entendu en même
temps faire des économies d'énergie euh
mais il y aura euh dans le même temps
une croissance industrielle on l'appelle
tous de nos vux euh et donc bonant Malan
nous aurons à augmenter le la quantité
d'énergie produite en France de au moins
50 % probablement d'ici 2005 50 et
probablement comme le dit RT d' à peu
près 20 % d'ici
2035 ce qui est donc important dans ce
dans ce moment là c'est de choisir une
route qui soit praticable chaque pays se
pose cette question et pour avoir
régulièrement des échanges à
l'international puisque EDF maintenant
en tant que chef de fil de la filière
nucléaire dans dans le domaine des
réacteurs a une responsabilité aussi
international vis-à-vis des industriels
partout où l' va dans le monde on trouve
des pays qui cherchent à atteindre
objectifs dans leur politique
énergétique ils veulent tous évidemment
à terme alors certains disent 2050 d'
2060 d' 2070 mais je dirais peu importe
ils veulent un système énergétique le
plus décarboné possible ils veulent
évidemment une compétitivité des coûts
de leur énergie et à tout le moins vous
l'avez dit monsieur le rapporteur une
stabilité des coûts de leur énergie qui
a probablement une valeur importante
aussi c'est pas seulement le le coout
moyen je dirais mais aussi sa stabilité
ça ve opposer sa volatilité qui est un
enjeu ils veulent une souveraineté
énergétique c'est-à-dire que les pays se
sont rendus compte de plus en plus et
malheureusement en particulier avec les
épisodes qui arrivent depuis 2 ans que
dépendre d'autres sphères géopolitiques
pour son énergie c'est tout simplement
despendre d'autres sphères géopolitiques
pour son avenir et ils veulent que si
possible ça crée des emplois chez eux
c'est ça les quatre enjeu que on trouve
partout dans le monde quand on quand on
cherche quand on regarde les politiques
énergétiques alors il se trouve que la
France dans le domaine de
l'électricité pour une grande partie par
talent et puis un petit peu par chance
quand on regarde la décarbonation a déjà
un système électrique qui est comme ça
système électrique qui repose
essentiellement sur les le renouvelable
en particulier hydroélectricité belle
photo derrière nous et le nucléaire qui
apporte en fait dans l'électricité ces
quatre facteurs maintenant il faut
l'étendre à l'ensemble de l'énergie ce
qui est un ce qui est un défi absolument
considérable la voie praticable que se
fixe la France dans ce domaine là c'est
finalement de se dire il faut faut que
je parie sur plusieurs sources en même
temps évidemment le développement du
renouvelable qui est absolument
indispensable sous toutes ses
formes le la prolongation du parc
nucléaire existant qui est un actif
extraordinaire et qui présente un double
enjeu il il est performant pour le pays
il faut donc essayer de l'emmener le
plus loin possible et il a le revers de
la médaille d'une magnifique histoire
industrielle 54 réacteurs sur 56
aujourd'hui 58 anciennement qui étaient
en exploitation 54 ont été mis en
service en 15 ans ça a été rappelé par
par bar c'est dire si on les amène tous
au même âge on ferme 54 réacteurs en 15
ans ce qui fait une barrière et une
falaise à la descente qui est évidemment
insupportable et donc il faut à la fois
qu'on prolonge nos réacteurs et puis il
faudra qu'on travaille à l'étalement de
leur arrêt pour finalement arriver à
faire le le lien avec le développement
du renouvelable et puis le troisième
levier qui est l'entrée de moyens
nouveau nucléaair faire le choix de
cette trajectoire qui consiste à
prolonger le parc nucléaire à construire
de nouveau réacteurs sous différentes
technologies et à à développer du ren
able et je pense une trajectoire
extrêmement sûre on peut on a trois
leviers et on peut en fonction de ce
qu'on va constater sur la progression du
renouvelable sur l'évolution de la
consommation appuyer plus ou moins
fortement sur les différents leviers
pour être à peu près sûr de suivre la
trajectoire d'évolution de la
consommation qui est nécessaire et de
continuer à décarboner le pays dans les
domaines non aujourd'hui couverts par
l'hydroélectricité al la prolongation du
parc on y reviendra sans doute dans vos
questions même si c'est pas strictement
dans mon scope et je pense qu'Étienne
but il y a 2 jours a déjà abordé des
points est un enjeu clé le grand carén
est déjà en cours on a énormément
d'enjeux pour aller à 60 ans mais aussi
pour aller au-delà de 60 ans beaucoup de
recherches qui sont menées au sein d'EDF
avec beaucoup de partenaires
internationaux d'ailleurs pour étudier
les questions de vieillissement des
installations évidemment les questions
de sûreté au-delà de 60 ans pour emmener
si ce n tous nos réacteurs en tout cas
un maximum de réacteur très au-delà de
de 60 ans il y a en effet cette décision
de construire ensuite un programme de
nouveaux réacteurs de type PR2 donc Joel
a rappelé ce qui était ces PR2 vous
pourraz revenir également dans vos
questions pour que je ne sois pas trop
lo dans prop introductif l'idée en effet
de tenir compte du retour d'expérience
des premiers op construits d'avoir un
réacteur qui depuis le début de sa
conception a un réacteur qui est qui est
conçu dans des outils digitaux ce qui
est absolument fondamental pour l'avenir
c'est les premiers op été construit ont
été construit dans une approche je
dirais papier ce qui contenu de la
complexité de ces objets et la
complexité des chantiers n évidemment
pas favorisant en 2025 on a g diré des
technologies qui nous permettent de
soutenir la conception par une approche
digitale et de soutenir le chantier
demain par une approche digitale ce qui
évidemment est un facteur de maîtrise de
maîtrise des projets on a surtout une
approche par série par paire et par
série et je veux insister sur ce point
qui est extrêmement important c'est ce
qui a marché il y a 40 ans on a
construit tous les réacteurs du parc par
paire ou par qure et par des
organisations par paire et et en série
34 réacteurs de type 900 MW 20 réacteurs
type 1300 MW et et c'est comme ça qu'on
atteint la maturité industrielle d'abord
parce que quand vous faites des
chantiers aussi complex si vous en
faites un de temps en temps c'est quand
même extrêmement compliqué de réussir
tout bon du premier coup et ensuite
parce qu' auudelà du chantier dans la
chaîne industrielle qui est derrière il
faut fabriquer des cuves des générateurs
de vapeur des alternateurs des turbines
des milliers de pompes si vous le faites
pour un réacteur vous ne le faites pas
non plus à un rythme industriel ce qui
ne permet pas l'investissement dans les
ressources humaines l'investissement
dans les capacités industrielles et
surtout la répétition du geste depuis 3
ans nous avons fait un travail très
important avec la filière nucléaire qui
a conduit en effet à la trajectoire de
charge et de ressources que que Joel bar
évoqué tout à l'heure mais qui a conduit
aussi à nous dire c'est quoi le rythme à
partir duquel on est vraiment industriel
dans le nucléaire et en fait c'est assez
étonnant parce que vous le preniez sous
l'le du génie civil de la construction
des équipements du domaine électrique et
cetera vous tombez toujours à peu près
sur le même chiffre il faut construire
1,5pr par an à peu près pour que les
usines soient chargées et que les gens
qui sont dans les usines fassent très
régulièrement les gestes ce qui veut
dire que assez vite ils les font tous
bien du Pr premier coup et dans un
niveau de qualité et de performance
efficace et c'est pourquoi nous nous
sommes situés dans cette trajectoire là
avec pour la France du coup avec le
programme qui est devant nous un PR par
an et une capacité d'exportation au
Royaume-Uni et en Europe qui vient faire
évidemment le complément de manière de
manière tout à fait indispensable en
dessous de C seuil là nous ne sommes pas
dans un Rupe industriel je crois que
c'est important à à l'avoir en tête donc
c'est évidemment cette proposition sur
la base de PR2 aujourd'hui nous avons
l'engagement d'une première série de 6
par trois paires et en effet la demande
de l'État et du gouvernement d'étudier
une extension à 14 ce qui représenterait
bon en Malan la mise en service d'un
réacteur par an à partir du milieu de la
décennie prochaine jusqu'en 2050 c'est
c'est c'est à peu près ça le c'est à peu
près ça le r en parallèle nous
travaillons effectivement sur un
réacteur de type SMR qui s'appelle
newward on est dans une puissance
beaucoup plus faible c'est des réacteurs
qui au lieu de faire 1650 1700 MW font
170 MW et on en met deux ensemble pour
faire une centrale de 340 MW l'objectif
est très assez simple là il y a un
marché mondial énorme qui est que si
tous les pays veulent vraiment se
décarboner ils vont devoir arrêter des
centrales qui fonctionnent aujourd'hui
au charbon au foule et puis plus tard au
gaz qui font dans leur grande majorité
entre 300 et 400
ma et donc si vous arrivez avec un objet
qui utilise le réseau au même endroit
qui l'utilise l'accès à la rivière ou à
la mer au même endroit et qui remplace
une cheminée à CO2 par une production
bac carbone en quelques années vous
aidez considérablement les pays à se
décarboner et donc EDF qui a dans sa
raison d'être d'aider d'aider la France
d'abord mais tous les pays dans lesquels
nous nous sommes actifs à décarbonner
leurs économies en fait a fait ce choix
un réacteur de plus petite taille ça
veut dire que on ne gagne pas l'économie
sur la taille du réacteur on gagne
l'économie sur l'effet de série et dans
les usines qui fabriquent des modules
qu'on vient assembler sur le site pour
faire ces réacteurs c'est une approche
très différente les facteurs clés de
réussite de ces de ces projets sont sont
je dirais d'abord la
continuité j'ai toujours du mal à faire
partager l'effort immense que nous avons
à faire depuis 7 8 ans pour remettre en
marche une une filière nucléaire qui est
capable de dérouler des projets
nucléaires neufs c'est un effort
colossal parce qu'une fois que vous
l'avez stoppé ou vous l'avez
insuffisamment entretenu l'effort de
remise en route est colossal on le
mesure souvent mal quand on est à à
l'extérieur et moi-même j'ai eu du mal
au début à le mesurer ça se niche dans
plein de choses nos capacités
industrielle en France qu'on est en
train de reconstituer la seniorité de
nos compétences quand vous avez arrêté
un moment le développement du nucléire
ça veut dire que les gens qui
commençaient à être les piliers d'une
organisation qui avait 40 45 ans Ben
depuis sont partis à la retraite vous
n'avez plus les piliers donc vous avez
un sujet non seulement de ressources en
volume mais vous avez un sujet de
ressources en seniorité et en capacité à
à à articuler les choses et puis bien
entendu l'expérience dans la maîtrise
des projets complexes alors nous avons
connu un certain nombre de débirs que je
pourrais sur lesquel je pourrais
certainement répondre à des questions
auprès de vous sur les les premiers
projets
pr nous sommes à quelques semaines et
dans la dernière ligne droite de
discussion avec l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire pour pouvoir charger le
combustible à Ferville 3 hein donc ce
qui sera évidemment une une étape
importante et nous faisons un travail
dans l'organisation deedf pour bien
mettre en place les différentes parties
de l'organisation indispensable une
maîtrise d'ouvrage forte qui est le
clients des projets qui qui tient je
dirais le le business plan les
hypothèses de performance et les les
hypothèses fonctionnelles des des
projets des directions de projets fortes
Onon a mis en place depuis plusieurs
années et qui commencent à rendre des
services chacun des projets est dirigé
par un directeur de projet qui est
rattaché à un membre du comité exécutif
de DF dans la plupart des cas à moi en
l'occurrence et ce qui signifie que il
est pleinement responsabilisé quand il a
besoin d'arbitrage il est tout de suite
en contact avec les instances de
gouvernance de DF il n'est pas enfoui
dans une organisation euh dans
lesquelles il aurait du mal à à à à être
agile une ingénierie qui c'est
complètement recentré autour de de la de
la délivrance des des des des études et
de l'exécution des de l'exécution des
chantiers et puis un travail avec la
filière comme vous m'avez demandé de
faire 10 minutes je veux pas beaucoupêre
long mais je vais terminer sur la
filière euh la filière nucléaire
aujourd'hui en effet c'est 220000
emplois
cœur dans des entreprises de dans les
grands donneurs d'ordre he et des
exploitants qui sont EDF le CEA
landandra Orano framatom qui est à la
fois un exploitant et un industriel des
des grandes entreprises de rang 1 génie
civiliste chaudiériste équipementier et
puis beaucoup d'entreprises qui
interviennent en rang 2 3 voir jusqu'à 4
en fait pour dans les dans les grands
projets 220000 emplois qui en effet comp
tenu de tout ce que nous avons à faire
dans la filière et encore ce chiffre
n'inclut pas les travaux de de
d'investissement nouveaux à l'aval du
cycle chez Orano devront être 280000 à
peu près en début de la décennie 2030 ce
qui comptenu des départs à la retraite
nécessite de recruter 100000 personnes
euh dans les dans la dans la dizaine
d'années que nous avons devant nous
10000 personnes par an ça a été dit du
cap à l'ingénieur dans tous les domaines
de
spécialité c'est le plus grand défi que
nous avons devant nous nous avons des
défis de stabilisation et de
finalisation de la conception comme ça a
été dit nous avons des défis de
compétitivité de bonne articulation avec
les fournisseurs nous avons des défis
d'optimisation du planning mais notre
plus grand défi c'est celui des
ressources c'est c'est c'est le défi qui
si on ne s'y met pas avec une énergie
folle ne va pas se réaliser tout se
donc nous avons mis en place une
université des métiers du nucléaire qui
est en effet une université hors les
murs elle est là pour fédérer le tissu
de formation public privé initial et
continu français pour amener à l'échelle
en fait les les nos capacités de
formation nous faisons un travail auprès
des jeunes parce que ça se joue au
collège et au lycée pour amener les
jeunes et en particulier les jeunes
filles vers l'industrie et le nucléaire
dans l'institement supérieur long
aujourd'hui nous n'avons que 20 % de
femmes dans l'enseignement supérieur
cours technique 10 % il y a aucune
raison donc un enjeu considérable
d'amener les jeunes et en particulier
les jeunes femmes vers les métiers de
l'industrie et vers les métiers du
nucléaire et puis nous faisons un
travail à l'échelle européenne la
filière nucléaire française aujourd'hui
c'est à peu près la moitié de la filière
nucléaire européenne il y a maintenant
16 pays européens je compte le
RoyaumeUni dedans je le permettraz qui
se sont déclarés en faveur du nucléaire
soit d'en démarrer soit d'en reprendre
et donc tous ces pays vont avoir le même
effort de de de développement à faire
EDF a non seulement responsabilité
évidemment cœur en France mais aussi la
responsabilité d'aider la filière
française à se développer à
l'international en particulier en Europe
et donc la notre capacité à regarder la
le dimensionnement industriel et de
ressources humaines pour le nucléaire
existant et pour le nouvel nucléaire 9
se joue pour beaucoup à l'échelle
européenne où énormément de projets vont
avoir lieu dans les années qui viennent
voilà si je ne prends pas plus de temps
le tableau général et je serais très
heureux de répondre à vos questions sur
les différents thèmes merci monsieur
hursa je vais laisser la parole à
Monsieur le rapporteur pour les
questions merci monsieur le Président
euh on a une collègue qui doit partir
assez vite je Denis SAÉ je sais pas si
tu as une question à poser avant ton
départ non donc merci merci pour vos
exposés euh
j'ai moi j'ai j'ai bien écouté
euh on se pose des questions assez
précis quand même sur les les
perspectives de consommation on a vu
qu'avec le parc historique on pouvait
remonter et puis avec flamandville sans
doute avec l'ouverture de de
flamandville on devrait remonter vers
les 400 tawh par an euh alors qu'on a
déjà atteint 420 mais on pourrait être
autour des
400 on sent qu'on a une petite un petite
problématique par rapport à la
consommation et à notre production entre
2030 et 2035 une problématique certaine
même au-delà on se dit que effectivement
le programme pourrait rentrer le
programme alors de de PR2 que que vous
nous avez signalé c'estàd 14 PR2
euh 6 + 8 avec la phase
d'industrialisation
euh ce que je comprends c'est 14 PR2 ça
ferait x 1,6 ça fait 22,4 GW euh 22,4
c'est pas ce qu'on a aujourd'hui he
aujourd'hui on a plutôt une soixantaine
non euh de GW ça veut dire que
vraisemblablement déjà si on se dit que
bah on allait à 60 ans pour la plupart
des reeurs bon au-delà 60 ans je crois
que le premier qui est qui est encore en
fonctionnement qui date de 1978 he c'est
cpuget qui date de 78 donc 78 ça fait
38 après est-ce que vous avez des
courbes moi j'aimerais j'aimerais avoir
des choses précises qui nous disent et
je pense que là DF doit doit avoir ça
mais il faudrait qu'on puisse nous les
transmettre des courbes avec des
hypothèses en se disant ben voilà si
tous les réacteurs devaient s'arrêter à
40 ans qu'est-ce que ça donne si tous
les réacteurs devaient s'arrêter à 60
ans qu'est-ce que ça donne si tous les
rcteurs devaient s'arrêter à 80 ans
qu'est-ce que ça donne et à quel moment
qu quelle décroissance et ça dans le
temps qu'on puisse avoir une vision très
claire sur ce sujet-là ça ça c'est c'est
c'est une première question c'est plus
une demande qu'une question d'ailleurs
mais parce que c'est pas la peine de de
nous donner tous les éléments là et moi
je préfère les avoir les avoir par écrit
mais c'est c'est quelque chose dont on a
besoin et
et qu'est-ce que par rapport à ces
différentes hypothèses le programme de
PR2 que vous annoncez à 14 PR2 qu'est-ce
que ça donne qu'est-ce que ça donne par
rapport à ça si on arrête s'arrête à 40
ans avec le PR2 commence en
2035 quelle monté en puissance et
comment comment on s'y retrouve pareil
sur 60 pareil sur 80 pour voir ce que ce
que ça donne en terme de
production nucléaire parce que ça me
semble important donc ça c'est c'est
déjà pour moi pour moi une première
opération un peu clarté sur ces
perspectives dans le nucléaire j'ai
senti dans vos propos que vous aviez
confiance dans la possibilité de relancé
dans un horizon raisonnable c'estd que
2035 VO un peu au-delà une
industrialisation des pr alors le PR2
moi j'ai compris c'était optimisé une
version optimisée moi j'ai plutôt
entendu aussi version simplifiée de le
Pr qui était assez complexe et qui fait
que s'il a coûtait aussi
cher
donc moi j'ai une question de fond c'est
de me dire on a été capable dans les
années 70 80 90 de faire effectivement
énormément de de centrales qu'est-ce qui
nous empêcherait aujourd'hui de refaire
les mêmes centrales avec le 4e carénage
puisque on fait un 4è carénage pour les
pour poursuivre leur leur durée de vie
le 4è carénage tient compte bien sûr des
des contraintes de sécurité
supplémentaire qu'on a aujourd'hui par
rapport à ce qui existait dans les
années 70 80 on peut considérer que
c'est le progrès
hein mais est-ce que le progrès ça
serait de pas réussir à refaire ce qu'on
a déjà fait dans les années 70 80 et
quelle différence il y aurait entre
ces ces centrales
historiques modernisées si je peux les
appeler comme ça avec les PR2 les PR
simplifiés est-ce qu'il y a voilà je
sais pas en terme de coût moi j'aimerais
avoir une comparaison des coûts me dire
tiens finalement les centrales on a leur
plan c'est on sait les faire et euh
qu'est-ce que ça produit et et quel est
le coût au kilwh de de ce programme là
par rapport à programme de perd est-ce
que c'est une question qu'on s'est posée
est-ce qu'on se l''est pas posé du tout
euh voilà est-ce que c'est complètement
idiot j'en sais rien c'est euh ensuite
euh effectivement les PR2 je pense que
ma première observation sur une demande
de de clarification des des perspectives
sur 80 ans de de de production nucléaire
répondra au fait que 14 c'est suffisant
c'est pas suffisant c'est trop moi je
pense que c'est pas assez mais bon après
on on y verra plus clair par rapport à
cela et puis euh ensuite moi j'ai j'ai
une question sur la la 3è génération
ou la 4e
euh les neutrons rapides les
centrales et euh Astrid est-ce que
Astrid a été arrêté est-ce qu' est
vraiment arrêté est-ce qu'on peut le
recommencer est-ce qu'on peut le
reprendre pour moi c'est pas comme
fenhe on m'a expliqué que on pouvait pas
on était en train de démanteler que
voilà c'était c'était sans doute quelque
chose qui coûterait nettement plus cher
que contre chose que que de remonter
mais est-ce que Astrid c'est on a mis
une croix définitive sur Astrid ou
est-ce que c'est quelque chose à partir
du moment on relance la filière qu'il
faudrait aussi avoir dans notre besace
pour l'avenir
je vous laisse répondre ensuite on
passera la parole pour les questions à
nos collègues les deux oui on va faire
ça dez-yzy on va faire ça on va faire ça
à deux alors d'abord je comprends
complètement votre question monsieur le
rapporteur sur les sur les courbes de
production donc je pense que c'est
quelque chose que nous pouvons vous
fournir sans grande difficulté il s'agit
d'estimation dEDF bien entendu non mais
je tiens à le préciser puis que dans la
dans la mission deodf il n'y a pas né il
n a plus nécessairement aujourd'hui
prévision de de des trajectoires de
consommation ça n'empêche pas qu'étant
en effet le premier acteur du de sur ce
marché là nous puissions le faire donc
nous avons fait des hypothèses en effet
avec différents scénarios de de durée
d'exploitation et de rampe de d'arrêt
comme je disais tout àheure des
réacteurs existants avec l'arrivée des
PR2 et puis différents niveaux de
pénétration des des énergies
renouvelables sachant que nous avons
essayé de faire un effort dans nos
scénarios c'est que chaque scénario soit
réaliste c'est qu'on peut faire des
scénari vous rentrez énormément
d'énergie renouvelable par exemple et je
suis à fond pour mais si on sait pas
équilibrer leur production avec la
consommation dans l'année parce que ça
nécessite soit beaucoup
d'investissements de réseau soit
beaucoup d'investissements de stockage
et qu'on est pas sûr de savoir les faire
alors ça pose un problème donc nous les
les trajectoires qu'on a établis sont
des trajectoires dans lesqueles on
considère que le système fonctionne
voilà c'est c'est un point important
hein c'est un point important donc on
vous fournira on vous fournira ces
éléments ce qui sera important aussi
pour nous justement par rapport à ça
c'est que peut-être que vous avez
identifié peut-être les points de
blocage éventuels ouou à certains
scénarios et si si on peut avoir ces
points de blocage aussi identifié c'est
pas mal parce que on aura aussi des
interlocuteurs qui vont nous parler des
réseaux et du système
global ça il faut qu'on puisse bien
sûr les coup des raccordements voilà
l'intérêt d'ailleurs des petits
réacteurs au passage dont je parlais
tout à l'heure là de type new c'est
qu'ils peuvent être multi-usage alors
bon ils sont fait un peu naturellement
pour envoyer l'électricité sur un réseau
électrique comme les gros mais ils
peuvent aussi servir à d'utres usages
par exemple alimenter une plateforme
industrielle pour éviter si une
plateforme industrielle se décarbone se
décarbone rapidement et transfert vers
l'électricité beaucoup d'usages qui sont
fossiles aujourd'hui si vous devez lui
amener une ligne 400000
euh c'est quand même autre chose que si
vous vous débrouillez localement donc ça
peut aider à décarboner des plateformes
industrielles il y a pas que
l'exportation voilà exactement il y a de
la production de chaleur on peut les
connecter notre objet newbard il est
directement travaillé avec le CEA et est
directement connectable à un
électrolyseur d'hydrogène
en prenant à la fois l'électricité qui
sort du réacteur mais aussi la chaleur
qui sort du réacteur pour faire une
électrolyse rendement qui permet d'avoir
un hydrogène moins cher et d'ailleurs au
passage un des soil hydrogène sans CO2
parce que avoir de l'hydrogène c'est
bien mais si vous avez émis du CO2 pour
le produire ça a un intérêt assez limité
de d'avoir obtenu un gaz explosif en
ayant consommé du
CO2 voilà donc et dernier usage de ces
réacteur en les positionnant bien sur le
territoire ils peuvent éviter du
développement de réseau or aujourd'hui
je suis très conscient que développer
des nouveaux sites nucléaires c'est un
enjeu mais développer des nouvelles
lignes 400000 VTS dans notre pays c'est
presque un enjeu encore plus
difficilein donc c'est c'est quelque
chose àê donc on on vous fournira ces
éléments alors votre deuxème question
autour de des PR2 et des alternatives je
dirais alors qui est une question
qui en fait j'ai je suis dans cette
fonction depuis pile 9 an mars 2015
c'est parmi les premières questions que
je me suis posé que quand vous avez ces
responsabilités vous dites bon on
réfléchit à ce que vont être les
réacteurs pour des séries cette fois-ci
en France demain pas juste un seul mais
d'une série et donc envidemment le choix
technologique est est important alors la
la l'approche de la France en matière de
sûreté qui est extrêmement exigeante
mais mais aussi je pense extrêmement
saine c'est de demander à aux réacteurs
qui sont dans exploitation vous le savez
tous les 10 ans de passer leur examen de
sûreté et de faire un certain nombre de
travaux et dans l'esprit de ces travaux
en particulier on essae constamment de
se se ramener à l'état de l'art en
matière de sûreté mais autant qu'on peut
fait que nos réacteurs aujourd'hui ont
un niveau de sûreté bien supérieur au
niveau de sûreté qu'ils auraient si on
les avait laissé tel quel depuis 1980 ce
qui qui est entre par entre nous l'
proche américaine par exemple vous ne
bougez pas pendant des décennies sauf
sauf sujet totalement indispensable
voilà donc déjà on a cette on a cette
dimensionlà donc ça fait de ces
réacteurs des réacteurs certes de 2e
génération dans leur conception mais qui
ont emmagasiné par exemple le retour
d'expérience de
Fukushima par exemple toutes sortes de
choses sur le rapport à
l'environnement déjà un certain nombre
de choses dans l'adaptation au
changement climatique et la prochaine
visite décenale la 5e va probablement
être assez tourné autour des enjeux de
changement climatique puisqu'on va
emmener les réacteurs loin dans le temps
il faut que eux-mêmes vivent dans des
paysages et dans des conditions
thermiques d'eau et de et d'air qui sont
pas cell pour lesquelles ils avaient été
conçus au départ
voilà quand vous passez à la trème
génération qui est celle des
PR vousit
fait plusieurs sous quand
même d'abord il est demandé au récteur
de 3è génération même si les reeurs deè
génération sont extrêmement sûr d'avoir
réduit autant que possible et encore au
moins d'un facteur 10 le risque qu'il
arrive un événement significatif premier
point deuxème ancien événement
significatif arrive vous devez le
confiner sur le site c'està-dire avoir
autant de disposition que vous pouvez
pour maîtriser l'événement pour le
confiner totalement sur le site voyz
prend l'exemple dans le P si il arrivait
l'équivalent de ce qui se'est passait
sur la le 4è réacteur de Fukushima ou le
le le le le combustible a fondu dans la
cuve et où se construit s'appelle un
corium c'està-dire un un petit soleil
d'uranium et de de toute sorte de dérivé
de l'uranium qui devient une espèce de
boule de plusieurs milliers de mgaw
thermiques qui finit par traverser la
cuve et là Fukushima a traversé la cuve
elle est partie bon d' les les sujets
que vous avez connu à flamandville enfin
dans les es de manière générale vous
arrivez dans un cendrier qui est en
dessous qui est construit dans un béton
réfractaire d'ailleurs l'objet de de
brevet français FC
Framatome qui lui-même va se dissoudre
avec le pour répartir ce combustible il
est il a des systèmes de refroidissement
dessous et bref il va rester là il va
être refroidi le réacteur sera
inutilisable sera plus utilisable mais
vous n'avez aucune condition conséquence
radiologique à l'extérieur du
site on est dans un gap quand même en
matière alors sur nos 4è visite décennal
on a fait des travaux pour s'approcher
le plus possible de ça on a installé des
systèmes sous les bâtiments réacteur
voilà bon mais on est on est quand même
il y a une petite différence et puis il
y a la dimension
sécuritaire sur un les réacteurs de la
classe pr vous avez une double enceinte
ou sur le PR2 une enceinte simple et
très épaisse en béton qui couvre tous
les équipements cœurs c'estd le bâtiment
réacteur dans lequel il y a la réaction
nucléire les bâtiments auxiliaires dans
lesquels vous avez tous les systèmes de
sûreté et le bâtiment combustible dans
laquelle il y a la piscine dans laquelle
vous avez les assemblages combustibles
prêts à être utilisé ou qui ont été
utilisés tout tout cela est dans une
coque en béton qui est qui est réputé
résistante à à des agressions très
élevées et c'est
évidemment pour les réacteurs qu'on
installe aujourd'hui et et qui vont
vivre jusqu'à la fin du siècle dans un
dans un monde qui est devenu un peu
incertain je vais je vais le dire comme
ça un argument extrêmement important qui
nous a amené à penser que il n'était
plus possible d'envisager de construire
en France autre chose que des réacteur
3è génération c'estàdire où il y a
toutes ces dispositions de réduction
ultime de la probabilité d'accident de
confinement d'un risque conséquence d'un
éventuel accident et de disposition de
sécurité alors ça un vrai coût ça un
vrai vrai coût dans un PR vous avez
beaucoup beaucoup plus de béton que dans
les réacteurs de la génération Pr
prédente c'est un fait voilà
voilà alors c'est c'est une discussion
qui est toujours difficile je la réserve
à cette commission
d'enquête et la représentation nationale
c'est très difficile vous voyez de dire
quand on fait un è il est plus sûr que
les
précédent c'est très difficile parce que
tout le monde entend le précédent est
moins sûr en fait éidemment les
réacteurs qui sont actuellement en
exploitation ils ont des niveaux de
sûreté hyper élevés en plus vous pouvez
faire confiance à nos autorités frça qui
les contrôle ils ont un niveau de sûreté
hyper élevé il a été estimé que ensuite
l'industrie nucléaire devait passer à
cette 3ème génération qui apporte encore
ce gap et qui était probablement
difficile d'imaginer redévelopper autre
chose et d'ailleurs aujourd'hui il y a
pas seulement la France il y a une
réflexion européenne là-dessus vous avez
des vous avez des des coordinations
entre les autorités de sûreté et puis
vous avez un un une organisation qui
s'appelle les eurur qui donne des des
règles de sûrté un peu communes à
l'intérieur de l'Europe et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ce qui est validé par les
euur ce ne sont que des réacteurs de 3è
génération voilà à la construction donc
c'est on est vraiment dans cette dans
cet état d'esprit voilà sur le PR2 on a
fait le
travail de on a fait un travail en effet
qui va dans le sens de alors
digitalisation comme je l'ai dit il est
soutenu par un outil digital depuis le
début ça c'est très
important standardisation alors ça faut
peut-être qu'on tu l'as évoqué Joel mais
qu'on s'arrête une seconde sur ce que ça
signifie quand vous prenez un réacteur
nucléaire vous avez les très gros bon
vous avez le béton vous avez les très
gros objets à l'intérieur la cuve dans
laquelle il y a la réaction les
générateurs de vapeur vous savez qui
dans lesquels on échange l'eau qui sort
de la cuve qui est très chaude et qui
avec celle qui revient de la turbine
froide pour faire de la vapeur qui
repart vers la turbine ce qui fait que
dans la turbine il y a une eau qui a
jamais été en contact avec la réaction
nucléaire la turbine alternateur qui
sont dans le Pr des des objets énormes
tout ça d'ailleurs de conception
française framatom et ex halstom euh et
puis vous avez plein de petits
équipements mais des dizaines de
milliers de kilomètres de tuyaux de de
Vann de pompe de de soupap voilà qui
font les systèmes de sécurité qui font
les équilibrages de pression et cetera
dans quand vous prenez unère comme
flamandville qui était donc le premier
de de la génération vous avez un
catalogue d'objets qui est colossal
c'est vous avez des milliers de
références de vannes de pome n'z pas
seulement des dizaines de milliers
d'objets vous avez en plus des milliers
de références c'estd si vous preneiez le
catalogue du nombre d'objets qu' y a
dans flamville c'est un catalogue énorme
sur le PR2 on a on a fait en sorte de de
réduire autant que possible ce catalogue
c'est de dire plutôt que d'avoir plein
de modèles de pompes différents on va
essayer d'avoir peu de modèles de pompes
différents trois
avantages au lieu de faire quelques
pompes d'un certain type puis à chaque
fois de changer ben vous faites beaucoup
de pompes d'un même type donc
l'industriel lui il fait toujours le
même objet il est plus efficace il est
moins cher quand vous
construisez toujours cette image du
meble Ikea imaginez un meble Ikea vous
aurez à construire dans lequel toutes
les vis sont différentes ou bien un meua
où toutes les vises sont identiques à
votre avis c'est le quel meuble que vous
montez le plus vite ça c'est clair donc
quand vous construisez évidemment si
vous avez moins de référence vous constr
vous reste un Nika prendre un truc plus
qualitatif si vous voulez mais mais
c'est c'est c'est l'idée et puis ensuite
en exploitation à maintenance c'est
aussi plus pratique donc on a
standardisé et ensuite on a simplifié
quand on dit qu'on a simplifié on a
surtout simplifier le génie civil on l'a
rationalisé donc au lieu qui double
enceinte en béton on a mis une seule
enceinte épaisse qui en fait la même
performance qui est plus facile à
construire euh on a euh rendu très
géométrique en fait tout le génie civil
des bâtiments principaux c'est dire
quand vous avez une cloison à un étage
on s'est arrangé pour que les cloisons
des étages en dessous soient tout aligné
donc quand vous construisez le bâtiment
c'est beaucoup plus simple à
flamandville vous avez des déc sur ces
aspects là vous avez des vous avez des
éléments que vous pourriez nous donner
de façon
synthétique de façon à ce qu'on puisse
expliquer expliquer voilà expliquer
est-ce que vous avez dit auparavant la
différence entre les les centrales
historiques modernisé avec Carn et ce
qu'apporte le Pr en plus et le coût le
coût effectivement qu'on puisse se dire
voilà voilà ce que ça apporte en terme
de sécurité je pense par exemple aux
avions je pense que une centrale
historique même avec le 4è carénage s'il
y a un avion qui tombe dessus alors ça
je vais pas vous l'écrire ça vous pouvez
pas nous l'écrire mais ce que je vais
vous ce que ve vous donner c'est c'est
qu'est-ce que c'est que non mais ça je
que vous comprenez qu'est-ce que c'est
que le P2 ce que je viens de vous
expliquer là qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans
les grands carénages et qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'une une centrale de 3e
génération voilà ça on vous on vous le
donne si si vous pouvez y rajouter ce
que ça coûte qu'est-ce que ça coûte
voilà en terme de de de projection parce
que le l'objet premier de la commission
d'enquête ce sont les prix à horizon en
particulier 20050 euh voilà les les les
coûts les coûts complets du nouveau
nucléaire vont commencer à impacter
évidemment ront une incidence sur les
prix à un moment donné donc quelles sont
vos projections en matière de coût euh
sur ces nouvelles technologies ouais
alors en matière de
coût on on a on est encore en travail je
vais vous expliquer où on en est euh et
on est encore en travail on n'est pas en
situation aujourd'hui de donner un coût
en euros par mgaw je mexlique pourquoi
on a fait un premier chiffrage tu tu
l'as évoqué tout à l'heure Joë du du
programme de 6 réacteur en 2021 le coût
est d'ailleurs sorti plus ou moins dans
la presse là vous avez entendu parler
sans doute 51,7 on va dire 52 milliards
pour dire autour de 52 milliards d'euros
de l'époque hein pour construire ces six
réacteurs alors c'est sur un certain
périmètre c'est vraiment le coût de
construction ça n'embarque aucun coût de
maîtrise d'ouvrage d'acquisition de
terrain de choses comme ça c'est
vraiment le coût de la construction des
six réacteurs sur un terrain réputé près
et
cetera on a on a fait l'année dernière
on a on a initié l'année dernière une
révisionmoi les les terrains c'est sur
les sites actuel donc il sont déjà
propriétés non
alors donc il y a pas d'achat de terrain
je m'explique bon c'est sur les sites
actuels
mais on a eu besoin d'acheter des
terrains des compléments de terrain
autour de no sites actuel donc ça ça
change rien c'est le site actuel on
déplace les barbelé à la fin mais mais
c'est contigu c'est c'est contigu au
site mais on
a dans les tris cas des sites dont on
parle là aujourd'hui qui vont être les
premiers sites on a eu à acheter des
terrains en périphérie du site qui est
officiellement le site de
DF donc on
a est on est en cours de refaire cette
cette évaluation économique donc c'est
le moment pour le faire tu expliquer
qu'on est en fin de du Basic design donc
le Basic design ça veut dire qu'on on a
fait la conception des des systèmes
c'est on a la description de tous les
systèmes le design détaillé ensuite vous
faites carrément les les plans
d'exécution vous faites tous les plans
de détail vous dites tel câble il va
passer sur tel chemin de câble tel tuyau
va s'accrocher là voyez ça c'est le
Detail design le Basic design c'est vous
avez toute la description de
l'installation de manière détaillée déjà
donc c'est au moment où on termine ça
qu'on refait notre évaluation des coûts
euh cette évaluation des coûts elle
intègre évidemment les retours des
fournisseurs qu'on a eu depuis 2021
euh et elle intègre évidemment tous les
derniers éléments qu'on a pu qu'on a pu
terminer sur le design
elle a conduit à un chiffre supérieur au
52 milliards c'est pas très étonnant on
a eu un de retour fournisseur un peu
au-dessus de ce qu'on imaginait on a
surtout un effet énorme d'inflation et
de coût de matière première qui a évolué
très fortement à la hausse entre 2021 et
sachant que le chiffre de 2021 daté
enfin reposé sur des hypothèses de 2020
et puis 2023 vous avez eu
une certaine explosion de de de plein de
cûts donc on a tombé sur un chiffre un
peu supérieur donc aujourd'hui on fait
un travail d'optimisation je ne
communique pas sur ce chiffre
aujourd'hui non non parce que il est il
est il est en cours de travail il est en
cours de travail ce chiffre ça sert à
rien quand on fait une estimation de
donner les étapes intermédiaires euh
maintenant on est en train de faire un
plan de compétitivité avec les
fournisseurs d'ici la fin de l'année ah
oui donc on l'aura pas la voilà euh
parce qu'on parce qu'on doit vous a pas
tout de parce qu'on doit faire un
travail complet parce qu'on doit finir
le travail avec les fournisseurs on est
en train maintenant de faire un
travailler avec tous les fournisseurs un
par un pour voir comment on peut
optimiser les hypothèses de design leur
façon de travailler les clauses
contractuelles pour optimiser le coup le
plus possible et surtout on va rentrer
dans la phase d'optimisation du
planning parce que ce qu'on s'apprête à
construire c'est pas seulement le
premier réacteur à panli c'est une série
on l'a dit fait au moins 6 peut-être 14
peut-être plus donc en fait le planning
unitaire d'un réacteur et en fait
d'ordre 1 sur le coût de l'euro par
mgawh à la fin parce que le
nucléaire c'est une industrie où vous
dépensez de l'argent pendant plusieurs
années avant de commencer à en gagner
donc le planning enfin la durée pendant
laquelle vous vous faites votre chantier
c'est d'ordre 1 sur le coût final
vraiment c'est d'ordre 1 l'autre chose
qui est d'ordre 1 c'est le montage
financier comment on va financer ces
réacteurs donc on est en train de le
travailler avec l'État là il y a
plusieurs plusieurs schéma en cours en
cours de de calage et donc aujourd'hui
il est il est il est difficile de vous
donner un un prê en euros par mgawh
parce qu'il dépend de la fin de notre
travail avec les fournisseurs de nos
hypothèses de planning et de la logique
de financement avec l'État on va
évidemment faire en sorte de de que ce
courous en euros par mgaw de la série
soit le plus bas possible c'est c'est
vraiment tout le travail qu'on doit
faire aujourd'hui et et EDF est embarqué
là-dedans parce que vous l'avez compris
sans doute avec les les règles de de
vente de l'électricité tes que nous les
avons calé maintenant avec l'État EDF a
elle-même est engagée à ce que le coût
de ces réacteurs soit le plus compétitif
possible excusez-moi j'éta peutêtre é
excusez-moi vous vous avez abordé le la
question du financement je je je voulais
vous interroger là-dessus et après on va
on va donner la parole à mes à mes
collègues euh j'ai j'ai j'ai compris
qu'il y avait évidemment le coût le coût
de l'argent le coût des des emprunts qui
vont être devoir être contracté va avoir
un impact sur les coûts les coûts finaux
euh l'entreprise aujourd'hui euh a été
euh si ce n'est nationalisé du moins
étatisé en tout cas son son son capital
euh
euh l'État peut peut être amené à jouer
un rôle important en allant emprunter
pour sur les marchés ou en donnant sa sa
sa sa signature sa garantie donc au
profit au profit de ce de ce programme
il y a aussi une possibilité qui existe
on le voit dans la dans la documentation
de mise en place d'une base d'actifs
régulé comme ça ça existe sur les réseau
c'est aussi peut-être envisageable pour
le le nucléaire nouveau et ensuite on a
et ça va nous faire revenir sur un point
que vous avez évoqué on a des
possibilités de mise en place de
contrats pour différence voire de PPA
qui pourrait permettre d'associer des
clients euh
importants industriels en particulier au
financement finalement d'une partie du
programme nucléaire enfin en
théorie vous vous en êtes où de de de
ces réflexion quells sont les les les
pistes qui sont
privilégiées sachant que les les modes
de d' accès d'accès au financement V
avoir encore une fois un impact sur le
sur les coûts finaux et sur le prix que
Pera au bout du compte le le
consommateur français qu'il soit
particulier ou ou
entreprise mais un peu difficile de
m'exprimer sur ce sujet là aujourd'hui
en tant que Def c'est sujet qui est
évidemment travaillé avec l'État en
particulier le ministère de l'économie
et des finances aujourd'hui on on ce
qu'on regarde ce sont des solutions de
financement qui impliquent EDF et l'État
sur le nouveau nucléaire nous n'ons pas
à date dans nos scénarios des des des
schémas avec d'autres financements donc
on est sur différents schémas de
financement entre DF et l'État il y a
plusieurs scénarios sur la table sur
lesquels il va falloir que qu'on tranche
également dans l'année avec l'État sur
sur la
logique ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est
que on doit naviguer dans un système
où il faut trouver la logique de
financement la plus efficace pour que le
coup en par mgaw à la fin soit le plus
bas possible il faut que la part que EDF
pour consentir à ce à ce financement
soit raccordable à sa propre trajectoire
financière qui elle-même assez
contraintes quand même vous connaissez
notre niveau d'endettement et et en fait
aujourd'hui on on commence à voir clair
sur la trajectoire de ressources qu'on
va avoir avec les dernières dispositions
qui ont été prises pour la valorisation
du nucléaire existant et l'intérêt de
monter le plus haut possible dans la
production nucléaire du parc existant et
du coup et du coup très clé parce que
c'est une source de revenu nette et
troisièmement il y a évidemment un
examen très très important qui est de
savoir en fonction du niveau de part l'é
et ses modalités comment va être
qualifié la forme d'aide d'État que ça
représente et ça c'est une question
d'ordre un
pourf fait allusion au contexte européen
très allusion au contexte européenil et
donc il faut qu'on trouve une solution
pour ça qu'on étudie plusieurs scénarios
et qu'il faut qu'on choisisse bien
meilleur le meilleur scénario avec
l'État qui fait le cou de financement le
plus efficace qui rentre dans la
trajectoire de DF et qui soit jugé
acceptable en terme d'aide d'État
apporté par la France au programme
nucléaire français il y aura forcément
une forme d'aide quelle qu'elle soit il
en aura forcément une mais il faut que
ça soit une aide d'État qui soit jugée
acceptable donc avec des contreparties
faibles voilà et et les partenariats
excusez-moi he de revenir là-dessus les
partenariats avec des des des des
consommateurs enfin des clients euh
important hein en parle pas de
particulier là hein euh c'est envisagé c
une envisagéourd'hui c'est très à
l'ordre du jour pour le parc pour le
parc existant donc aujourd'hui on pour
le parc existant on fait vraiment un
travail pour pour voir en fait qui
serait intéressé à à envisager des
contrats de long terme avec EDF sous une
forme de participation au aux
investissements et dépenses
d'exploitation du parc existant voilà ça
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un ça
serait original ça parce que ça alors
original non parce que en fait on on l'a
on l'avait en partie au moment de la
création du parc on avait dans la
création du parc c'est phénomène peu
connu mais il y avait quelques
participations dans des réacteurs du du
du parc nucléaire français existant
d'accord et ça c'est quelque chose
évidemment d'important comme ces
réacteurs sont en exploitation ça veut
dire que c'est un objet qui se met en
route assez vite vous voyez hein et pour
un client aujourd'hui quand même les
clients sont plus intéressés par
l'énergie l'énergie dont ils vont avoir
besoin en 2025 ou en 2030 que par
l'énergie dont ils vont avoir besoin en
2038 ou en 2040 voyez donc on est
beaucoup plus sur un schéma de de
contrat à long terme et de participation
sur le parc existant d'accord merci les
collègu Victorin on va on va prendre les
questions par deux merci collègue série
de de et si je peux me permettre
excusez-moi monsieur le sénateur juste
pour préciser que ce qu'on évoque ici
c'est-à-dire trouver une forme où il y a
une contribution de l'État dans des
proportions raisonnables et acceptbles
par les autorités de la concurrence
c'est une question qui se pose pour le
nucléaire mais qui s'applique déjà à
toutes les EnR he puisqueen fait c'est
aujourd'hui d'une façon ou d'une autre
les EnR se développent en France avec
des formes de de de
contribution de l'État qu'elle soit dans
les investissements ou qu'elle soit dans
la garantie des prix de
vente merci merci
victorel Hanel après merci monsieur le
Président je vous ai écouté
attentivement pour le bcien que je suis
j'ai l'impression que vous êtes
totalement préparé que le groupe DF est
totalement préparé alors pour ce que
nous recherchons et ce que recherche
l'état ce que nous recherchons leés le
rapporteur l'a dit c'est un mix
optimisé en décarbonation en changement
les élect ication des usages pouront
prix raisonnable et en faisant de
l'économie et de l'effacement je peux
résumer ça comme ça avec le programme
que vous évoquez j'ai l'impression que
on a rien perdu en terme de maîtrise de
la filière on avait maîtrisé ça entre 70
et 90 on a fait beaucoup de réacteurs et
on a fait une transition du fossile très
thermique au nucléaire très vite euh
aujourd'hui le rapporteur a posé la
question qu'est-ce qui empêche de faire
et de répéter ce qu'on a fait il y a
quelques quelques années ça c'est une
prière ch la deuxième chose est-ce que
EDF aujourd'hui maîtrise parfaitement la
filière et vous avez évoqué
simplification de PR2 pourquoi
simplification pourquoi c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui pourquoi est-ce que on a
maîtrisé clé en main ou avec des
délégations parfaitement la construction
les chinois sont allés apparemment plus
vite que nous et en maîtrisant peut-être
encore mieux que nous cette technologie
là avec
no au français est-ce que aujourd'huif
en coordination en maîtrise en grand
administrateur et capitaine d'industrie
est-ce que en soudage et cetera bref
est-ce que EDF aujourd'hui maîtrise
parfaitement
euh de manière systémique sil s'agit de
faire ce qu'on veut faire en
paramétrique de changer les prix ici ou
là il faut peut-être avec la nouvelle
loi sortir en en en système et et créer
un Big Bang énergétique est-ce est-ce
que on a les moyens de faire ça j' mets
une opinion personnelle et je m'arrête
là moi j'estime que depuis la loi nomme
l'objectif qu'on se fixe c'est de
baisser la part de l'énergie nucléaire
dans le système énergétique français a
donné des résultats que nous ne
maîtrisons pas du tout si on confie
l'intérêt national la sécurité
d'approvisionnement uniquement au marché
je dis qu'on est un peu naïf ensuite si
on continue ce que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui malgré les réformes
annoncées attendre 2025 pour avoir ce
bing bang là avec de l'injection
d'énergie intermittente que nous ne
maîtrisons pas ça veut dire chaque fois
qu'il faudra attendre qu'il y ait du
vent par exemple euh arrêter les
centrale nucléaire eu et et c'est pas
forcément très bon en terme de CO2
est-ce que tout ça est pris en compte
pour un mixte optimisé est-ce que vous
avez des simulations qui permettrai de
dire avec toute l'expérience accumulée
euh récemment avec les changements que
vous mettez en œuvre avec l'avantprjet
qui apparemment circule déjà il un avant
projet que la CRÉ a émis avec la DLC ils
ont émis une lettre envoyé une lettre au
au au gouvernement pour dire voilà les
ur à évité voilà ce que je vous demande
de respecter ce serait intéressant que
on étudie cela est-ce que donc vous
maîtrisez tout ça est-ce que vous pesez
sur l'avant projet et quel est le bing
bang vous vous préparer avec une
maîtrise parfaite de la filière
électronucléaire
français Henri hen
oui merci président merci
messieur vous nous avez indiqué qu'un
des défis majeurs c'était bien sûr les
ressources humaines avec donc sur 10 an
plus 100000 emplois alors est-ce que
j'ai bien compris plus 100000 avec donc
le renouvellement des 200000 déjà hein
voilà plus 100000 emplois donc moi
j'aimerais bien que vous soyez un petit
peu plus précis sur votre stratégie
parce qu'il existe aujourd'hui des
filières qui permettent donc de choisir
euh le nucléaire mais comment vous allez
devant donc cette montée en puissance de
ressources humaines comment vous allez
pouvoir attirer donc autant d'emplois
euh sachant que euh dans les difficultés
que nous avons connu de la corrosion
sous contrainte me semble-t-il on nous a
dit lors de certaines auditions qu'on
avait fait appel à de la mainœuvre
étrangère parce qu'on en avait pas assez
ici pour pouvoir réparer donc est-ce que
vous pourriez me me m'éclairer sur votre
stratégie justement de de cette montée
en
puissance question ensuite on passera la
parole à Stéphane piinir et à Daniel
gréier et Daniel salmon veut intervenir
aussi vous avez la parole merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre merci
pour votre pour votre question sur la
maîtrise de la filière
euh
je vais essayer d'être précis et modeste
dans dans ma réponse ou humble dans ma
réponse je pense qu'on peut dire que EDF
maîtrise bien la filière nucléaire
française s'agissant de toutes les
opérations pour le parc
existant où en fait l'activité ne s'est
jamais arrêté et où donc nous avons un
tissu de de partenaire de prestataire
pour toute la l'exploitation la
maintenance les révisions des cénales
des des des réacteurs qui est de bonne
qualité et qui n'a jamais arrêté de
travailler par hypothèse d'ailleurs pour
les centrales qui sont en fonctionnement
pour ce qui est de construire de
nouveaux réacteurs nous sommes en
rétablissement de la filière il faut
l'avoir en tête Flamanville nous a
permis de réapprendre même si ça a été
beaucoup avec beaucoup de douleur je
peux rentrer les détails si vous voulez
mais nous a permis de réapprendre ce qui
était la maîtrise d'un très grand projet
comme celui-là avec un vrai déficit de
compétences au départ on est parti avec
des équipes moins aguéries pour pour
fabriquer un objet plus complexe que
ceux qu'on avait fabriqué avant avec des
équipes à guéri hein c'est un peu ça le
sujet
euh on a réappris la construction on on
a réappris les les les choses trrappes
les points clés les enjeux de ces
projets on a aujourd'hui à continuer de
progresser avec la filière pour bien se
réaligner et pour avoir une filière qui
est dimensionnée à la hauteur dont on a
besoin et là il nous reste du travail on
a fait beaucoup de chemin dans les TR qu
dernières années il nous reste encore à
en faire dans les 3 qu années qui
viennent jusqu'à ce qu'on au moment où
on rentrera dans le vif du sujet du
chantier PL voilà il y a des questions
de capacités industrielles on a relancé
quand même des capacités industrielles
prenez l'exemple de des installations de
Framatome que ça soit au creusau la
grosse fonderie nucléaire ou que ça soit
à saint-marcelle à côté de chalonurson
le leur leur magnifique établissement
qui fabrique des générateurs de vapeur
ces deux établissements là avaient eu
mais une activité proche de la jachè
pendant 10 ans ils ont recommencé à
fonctionner à plein régime d'ailleurs au
passage grâce au projet d'inlep depuis
depuis 5 6 ans et puis là maintenant
parce qu'ils sont en train de commencer
de faire des pièces pour les PR2 on a
pris de l'avance on s'est dit qu'il vait
mieux prendre l'avance et puis peut-être
un moment donné ralentir que de prendre
que d'attendre trop on a complètement
restructuré ces installations le
Framatome a investi dans la fonderie on
a des presses des fours qui ont été
modernisés l'installation de
Saint-Marcel a été digitalisée voilà et
ça on est en train de le faire dans dans
plusieurs autres dans plusieurs autres
installation du pays on parle d'un pays
dans lequel quand on a fait le parc
nucléaire l'industrie représentait 25%
du PIB aujourd'hui c'est
11 l'avoir en tête et dans le 11
l'automobile et l'aéronautique pèent
assez lourd quand même donc on a on a
vraiment un travail de de de
restructuration qu'on est en train de
faire j'ai confiance mais un travail de
restructuration de la filière et de
réalignement de la filière et je vous
disais tout à l'heure le principal enjeu
probablement les ressources humaines
alors là ce qu'on a fait c'est Onet
créer cette université des métiers du
nucléaire elle a eu comme premier objet
de recenser toutes les formation qui
existe dans le domaine nucléaire en
France au début on se disait on va en
créer on en a trouvé 5000 donc on va pas
en créer hein c'est pas ça le sujet le
sujet c'est plutôt de faire en sorte
qu'ell soit sur les bons sujets qu'elles
ai des profs et qu'elles aient des
élèves ces formations et donc on fait un
on a fait un site internet pour aller
voir d'ailleurs s'appelle monavenirdl
nucléaire.fr tout attaché mon avenir
dans le nucléaire dans lequel vous avez
toutes ces formations dans lequel
progressivement les entreprises de la
filière viennent mettre leurs offres
d'emploi les offres de stage les offres
de formation sur en alternance on fait
un travail avec le ministère de
l'Enseignement supérieur et l'éducation
nationale pour que les filières
nucléaires arrivent j'espère peut-être
l'année prochaine dans le dispositif
d'orientation postback euh parcours
suple pour qu'on puisse visualiser qu'en
faisant telle formation on va aller dans
le nucléaire à la fin euh on fait des
des des des sessions en lycée collège
pour attirer les attirer les jeunes donc
on est vraiment lancé dans un dans un
dans un travail de fond autour des
installations et maintenant on est en
train de passer l'échelle régionale
c'est-à-dire dans les principales
régions concernées dans toutes les
régions en France il y a des activités
nucléaires mais vous avez l'île-de-fance
pour le tissu des ingénieurs la
Normandie l'é Haut- de- France auver
ronalpe et la région sud qui sont et
grandes qui sont particulièrement
concernés dans toutes ces régions on a
commencé d'aller travailler les IUT les
BTS des lycées professionnelles avec des
formations nucléaires qui sont accostés
aux central nucléaaires qu'on a à côté
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont des offres de
stage VO c'est vraiment un travail de
fond et dans la nouvelle organisation
deedf qu'on qu'on est en train de
préparer pour une mise en place au 2e
trimestre on va avoir des équipes
dédiées à piloter ça dans la période
précédente on l'avait on l'a fait avec
notre organisation précédente là on va
avoir des équipes dédiées à ça voilà et
parce que je pense que c'est en fait un
de nos enjeux un de nos enjeux
colossales je vais vous donner un
exemple si vous alliez sur le site de
l'onicep on est tous allé voir le site
de l'onicep quand on était étudiant moi
ça faisait longtemps que j'étais pas
allé vous alliez sur le site de l'onicep
le 30 octobre il était marqué à la au
chapitre filière nucléaire filière dans
l'avenir est est incertain euh en
décroissance d'activité euh
peut-être quand tu êtes un jeune de 17
ans à priori c'est pas vraiment là que
vous allez une fois que vous avez lu le
site de l'onicep bon on a fait un
travail avec le ministère Dean supériur
maintenant le le 10 le 10 novembre il y
avait marqué que c'était une filière
d'avenir euh dans laquelle il y avait
des formations intéressantes et cetera
voilà mais c'est un travail de fourmis
il faut aller partout pour réaligner les
gens vers vers ce métier on a une chance
immense c'est que dans les chez les
jeunes aujourd'hui l'enjeu climatique
est vu comme un enjeu considérable
considérable et donc comme on arrive
avec un objet qui certes comme tous les
objets a ses avantag et ces
inconvénients mais au moins et quand
même une vraie partie de la solution à
ce grand problème on a un vrai levier
d'adhésion donc faut vraiment travailler
sur ce sur ce mais on va avoir besoin de
toutes les ressources privé publ
politique sur C
sujet c'est bon tu la répon je donne la
parole à Stéphane Piednoir et Dani
griier tu demander je te Stéphan
Piednoir merci monsieur le Président euh
merci Monsieur pour vos vos propos
j'avais alors une question sur les SMR
d'abord sur le modèle économique vous
avez dit
et vous sa peut-être je suis assez
proche de la centrale à charbon de
cordemet que la présidente de région a
envisagé de de remplacer cette centrale
à charbon et d' installer un petit SMR
peut-être un New World sait-on jamais
quel est le modèle économique parce que
le charbon en en fait on est là aussi
pour parler des prix la production
d'électricité via le charbon est plutôt
rentable d'un point de vue économique
point de vue climatique c'est évidemment
une autre histoire est-ce que on a des
éléments là-dessus qui nous permettent
de dire c'est à la fois vertueux sur le
plan environnemental mais pas pas
déconnant si vous me permettez sur le
plan économique et puis la deuxème
question parce que je crois que c'est
rapporteur qui a posé la questions sur
Astrid et que ça n'a pas été tout à fait
abordé alors comme vous le savez que
c'est un sujet qui me tient à cœur en
tant que président de l'OPEX et
rapporteur sur ce sur ce sujet là en 19
euh donc Astrid a été arrêté mais
beaucoup de start-up s'emparent du
processus avec différentes technologies
enfin je vous fais pas la je vous fais
pas la leçon mais et ces start-ups sont
encouragés par par l'état français avec
des subventions assez conséquentes dans
le cadre du Plan France 2030 alors je
c'est plus une question pour pour Joel
Barry du coup parce que ça veut dire
qu'il y a une diversification des
producteurs d'électricité avec des
petits producteurs y compris du y
compris du mgaw pour certains est-ce que
tout cela comment tout cela s'inscrit
dans dans le futur paysage électrique du
du
pays Daniel grémier oui merci président
merci nos intervenants je vais être très
bref Astrid l'a posé la question
effectivement je suis avite de connaître
comme d'autres la réponse la deuxième
question que je voulais vous poser quand
imagineon les premières productions avec
les les modulaires SMR et et et troisème
question par rapport au refroidissement
des centrales où où en est-on au niveau
des technologie permettant effectivement
en fonction de l'évolution d'avoir une
Centrale qui est capable de produire 365
jours sur 365 hormis la partie bien sûr
contrôle nécessaire mais c'est de ne pas
être dans la situation
hypothétique d'une centrale qui a le
droit ou n'a pas le droit de fonctionner
par parce que l'eau est trop chaude
Daniel Salmon et ensuite on vous redonne
la parole pour répondre oui merci merci
pour votre présentation quelques petites
questions concernant l'évolution entre
PR2 et
PR1 il y a eu beaucoup de soucis avec
l'hydraulique de la cuve avec des
déstabilisation des des combustibles
j'ai cru entendre que cette cuve était
la même entrepr1 et PR2 j'aimerais bien
vous entendre sur ce ce sujet là
euh vous AES passé d'une double enceinte
à une simple enceinte donc vous vous
avez dit beaucoup beaucoup plus de béton
euh est-ce que il y a des calculs de
fait en terme d'énergie grise parce que
pour faire du béton faut beaucoup de
d'énergie donc est-ce que vous avez fait
ces calculs ça serait intéressant euh il
y
avait sur le PR1 on a parlé beaucoup de
redondance de circuit de secours euh
j'aiendre qu'il y en avait moins aussi
simplifieré sur le PR2 j'aimerais bien
aussi savoir ce qu'il en est vous avez
parlé également de modulation
euh qui serait supérieure et qui serait
sans doute plus facile sur les nouveaux
réacteurs on a entendu en début de
semaine quelqu'un de DF qui nous a dit
que sur les réacteurs actuels on pouvait
bien modulé donc est-ce que vous pouvez
nous nous refaire un comparatif entre
les deux parce que je pense que dans
l'hypothèse d'un mix avec bien entendu
beaucoup de
d'énergie renouvelable c'est c'est très
important dernière chose on parle
toujours d'une d'une grande fracture
dans la filière nucléaire avec des
compétences qui se sont qui ont disparu
pourtant quand on regarde on s'aperçoit
que civo 2 a été livré en 2002 et que le
chantier de Flam ville a commencé en
2007 on a on a 5 années donc comment se
fait-il que et avant et avant siiv il y
a eu quand même on a eu on a construit
quand même des réacteurs jusqu'en voilà
jusqu'en 2002 mais il y a eu 99 aussi
avec chose et comment ça se fait qu'on a
eu cette évaporation en peu de temps à
vrai dire merci Monsieur bar oui bah
écoutez merci monsieur le Président moi
je vais essayer peut-être de de de
répondre de donner un point de vue sur
les quelques questions que vous avez
poser d'abord je trouve que vous avez
posé des questions de
confiance et je vais vous dire pourquoi
moi je suis confiant dans le poste que
j'occupe depuis 15 mois dans un domaine
qui en plus est est tout nouveau pour
moi contte tenu de ce que j'ai fait dans
le passé je pourquoi je suis confiant
premièrement sur le vous avez posé
beaucoup de questions et vous avez
raison vous avez demandé à F de fournir
des courbes falaisees j'appelle ça les
courbes falaises c'està dire là la
diminution de la puissance installée des
REP des réacteurs actuellement en
service et la montée en puissance des
des réacteurs PR2 dont nous
parlons ces messieurs de d vont donner
des chiffres vous imaginez bien que moi
je me suis posé la question donc je
Donis pas mes chiffres parce que je ne
suis pas habilité à à me prononcer sur
ce sujet mais je suis quand même
confiant tenez je vais quand même vous
en donner un chiffre en 2050 en 2050
sous réserve de confirmation par
EDF si je fais l'hypothèse qu'on arrive
à prolonger tous les réacteurs
actuellement un service de 60 ans on
aura encore en 2050 à peu près 15 GW
install
résiduel et si on fait les 14 pr 2 don
nous avons parlure d'ici 2050 on va
rajouter donc
22sieur rapporteur donc on arrivera à
peu près àu de 40 g dans l'hypothèse on
limite la durée de vie réacteur à 60
ans vous l' dit tout à l'heure on va
essayer d'aller plus loin il pas de
raison que sur une technologie qui est
la même américains fasse 80 et que nous
on smite à 60 donc voilà ce que je veux
vous dire pourquoi je suis confiant sur
cette question là mais c'est une très
bonne question oui mais monsieur bar la
question est pas tant celle-là que que
que le fait que s'il y a un problème
technologique sérieux euh comment on
fait quoi sur le PR2 oui mais j'y viens
monsieur le Président voir sur le parc
existant qui serait confronté à des
difficultés du type de ce qu'on a connu
avec les
les les corrosions sous contrainte et
cetera personne ne le souhaite surtout
pas moi voilà non mais je pense que en
cumulant tous les arguments qu'on vient
de vous donner Xav et moi-même on a
quand même un certain comment dire un
certain taux de confiance sur les marges
dont on dispose mais vous avez raison de
réclamer des des des des courbes
précises là-dessus j'en profite pour
pour pour rebondir sur la remarque a
fait monsieur monsieur le sénateur Lurel
c'est vrai que moi la question que je me
suis posé sur cette sur cette énergie
électronucléaire depu je suis arrivé
c'est qui est le
systémier qui est le systémier et ben
EDF vous dira qu'il était dans le temps
me trompe pas mais qu'on lui a petit à
petit René ses responsabilités là Ren
ses responsabilités là et vous avez
raison monsieur le sénateur de souligner
que peut-être alors vous AZ loyé le mot
Big Bang pas aller aussi loin mais mais
il faut s'interroger
làdessus qui est le systémier du système
électrique français
aujourd'hui c'est
pas pas
les je me Perets vous interrompre en
revenant sur le déb début de votre
propos
liminire vous avez laissé entendre je
l'ai compris comme ça mais mal compris
que la non mise à disposition de la
PPE poser question est-ce que le fait
qu'on ne la connaisse pas aujourd'hui
qu'on n pas pu en débattre
qu'apparemment il en sera pas question
non plus dans la future loi euh euh
souveraineté
énergétique ne ne pose pas un problème
en terme de de de de de de
management et de conduite de stratégie
et de conduite de de de ce plan
industriel qui est gigantesque quoi je
vu vu de notre point de vue voilà c'est
c'est c'est c'est une vraie c'est une
vraie question mais je je je je vous
répondrai monsieur le Président non à ce
stade du projet nous moi je suis chargé
de superviser un programme de réaction
de de réalisation pardon de six
réacteurs PR2 en trois pair de de à à
panlieline et budget je suis convaincu
qu'on en aura besoin parce que je suis
convaincu qu'on aura besoin d'encore
plus que cela donc que la PPE ne soit
pas encore sortie je suppose quand même
qu'elle va sortir en 2024 enfin je peux
me faire cette hypothèse quand même en
étant confiant donc là ce que la D la
PPE doit terminé c'est combien
faudra-t-il exactement de PR2 de série
dont nous parlons depuis le début
d'audition mais c'est bien la question
oui oui mais aujourd'hui on travaille
sur ce qui ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il faut faire un premier palier de 6
par paire de de pour être capable de
démontrer qu'on sera capable de faire un
PR2 de série qui soit compétitif en
terme de délai de réalisation et de coût
d'électricité
produite c'est ça notre challenge et
c'est ça ce que vous expliquer ça c'est
ça donc l'imprécision sur le sujet pose
pose pas de problème tout va bien ah non
j'ai pas attendez monsieur le Président
ne caricons pas ce que j'ai dit je dis
pas que tout va bien je préférerais moi
aussi savoir qu' qu'il faut en faire 6 +
8 plus et cetera mais reconnaissons que
la première étape à franchir c'est de
passer des
prototypes qui ont connu un certain
nombre d'aléas que vous avez rappelé les
uns et les autres à flamandville à Inle
point à lioto et cetera a un mécanisme
de production industrielle que Don DF à
la charge et qu'il doit démontrer et
qu'il doit démontrer à travers ce
premier cette première phase de 6pr2 et
ça rejoint la question que vous posz sur
les coups tout à l'heure moi je
considère que certes il faut raisonner
sur le devis initial les fameux 52
milliards dont app av ça mais pour moi
c'est pas ça le plus important pour moi
le plus important c'est d'arriver à
démontrer qu'avec ce programme de 6 on
fait une tête de série de panl avec une
paire comme à HPC comme à incle point
qui soit significativement plus efficace
que celle point et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui je peux vous dire qu'on y
est hein dans les estimations actuelles
on est plus efficace que in point je me
trompe
pas me trompe pas ça aussi ça me fait
être confiance sur la tête de série et
surtout derrière il faut arriver
effectivement au budget hein dans les
les les 5e et 6e réacteurs de cette de
cette production des cist à quelque
chose qui sera compétitif en délai de
réalisation et en cou sur le délai de
réalisation vous avez entendu les
annonces qu'a fait qu'a faite qui ont
été fait par EDF sur sur
HPC c'est pas satisfaisant c'est pas
réjouissant mais c'est quand même ça
montre quand même qu'on progresse entre
je parle s contrôle def sauf erreur de
ma part en délai de réalisation entre le
premier béton et la mise en service
industriel entre flamandville et inkle
point on est passé de 18 ans à 12 ans on
progresse on progresse il faut aller
encore plus loin je pour vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui sur ce délai là on a un
objectif encore plus ambitieux mais
comme l' ditav ça tout à l'heure il faut
y travailler encore un petit peu pendant
petite année pour arriver à des
conclusions des définitif ok merci
monsieurursa pour la la réponse aux
questions qui a été posé pardon j'ai
oublié de répondre sur les les les
neutrons rapides allez-y allez-y là vous
avez tout à fait raison monsieur le
sénateur d'abord effectivement moi je me
prononcerai pas sur Laar Stre j'étais
pas là donc euh mais sur le redémarrage
oui mais mais alors attendez qu' faille
qu' faille travailler sur le neutron
rapide moi j'en suis convaincu parce que
tout simplement sur le plan de
l'acceptabilité sociale sociétale du
nucléaire
on a si je puis dire entre guillemets
passz-moi l'expression deux épines dans
le pied c'est la dépendance à l'uranium
d'un côté et c'est la gestion des
déchets de l'autre donc tout ce qui va
dans le sens d'une résolution plus ou
moins complète plus ou moins définitive
de ces deux problème là et va dans le
bon sens c'est pour ça qu'il faut
effectivement il faut effectivement
soutenir les projets de réacteur à trop
rapide de de nos amis start-up qui sont
proposés au CEA qui est chargé de les
coordonnés les accompagner tout à fait
d'accord avec vous et la deuxième raison
c'est que moi je ne connais pas de
filière industrielle j'en ai connu dans
ma jeunesse si je peux dire he dans le
spacial dans l'armement ou autre qui ne
puisse subsister qui puissent subsister
pardon sans politique de recherche et
développement pour attirer les meilleurs
les jeunes ceux qui sont motivés et
cetera d'ailleurs on le voit aujourd'hui
je suppose que DF va seter ou déjà
peut-être en train de seter à des
départs de chez vous qui partent dans
les
start-ups faut faire attention à ça ça
arrive partout moi je l'ai connu dans le
spatial je l'ai connu dans l'armement
vous vous le connaîrez si vous ne
connaissez pas déjà dans le nucléaire
fondamental ou inversement ou
inversement mais c'est bien c'est bien
c'est ça qui entretient l'émulation et
les capacités et les capacités de de
d'attractivité de de notre filière donc
c'est quelque chose que moi je soutiens
tout à fait même si encore une fois ce
n'est pas du tout dans mon périmètre moi
on me dit mon périmètre c'est la 3e
génération n'empêche que j'ai un avis
sur la 4e sûr ça oui moi jeis pour
rester sur ce sujet avant venir sur les
autres du côté de def on est également
très finalement intéressé et favorable
par qu'il y a un mouvement sur les
réacteurs avancé de de de 4e génération
plutôt de petite taille aujourd'hui
alors c'est vrai aujourd'hui on
concentre nos nos efforts sur
l'ingénierie et le développement de la
3è génération parce que le métier deedf
c'est quand même de produire le plus
vite possible de l'électricité et
décarboner le pays mais en même temps on
a une part d'activité dans notre RD et
dans dans notre ingénierie qui est mise
à à suivre finalement les développements
qu'il y a dans les différents Amr
aujourd'hui qui existent en France donc
certains en effet font font l'objet
d'être significatif de la part de l'État
et on s'interdira pas de participer à
ceux qu'on trouve les plus pertinents
voilà on pense simplement qu'ils
annoncent des plannings très ambitieux
et que les plannings réels seront un peu
plus loin maintenant de temps en temps
il peut y avoir une très bonne surprise
he ça peut arriver aussi dans le
foisonnement des idées donc on est
plutôt dans ce suivi on pense que c'est
plutôt une bonne chose qu' un écosystème
nucléaire avec aussi des start-ups qui
réfléchissent différemment je pense que
c'est aussi une bonne chose sur les SMR
le modèle d'activité alors le SMR c'est
un c'est une idée très séduisante au
départ d'abord parce que notre monde
aime bien dire small is beautiful ça va
être plus facile il y a plein de choses
qui vont être plus facile en réalité la
complexité se cache un petit peu dans
les dans les détails le SMR il peut
trouver le le la cible économique mais
il faut qu'il fasse des séries en
dizaines lui pour le coup si vous voulez
avec un objet comme new ça sera encore
plus vrai pour des objets plus petits
retomber à peu près sur les sur les
coûts en euros par mgawatt là je parle
du cou je parle pas du financement je
parle de l'investissement en euro par
mgaw si vous voulez retomber à peu près
sur les cûpts de le Pr il faut faire des
dizaines voilà c'est il y a pas un
chiffre miracle hein mais c'est pas
c'est pas 5 6 c'est plutôt 20 50 voilà
et donc tout de suite vous tombez sur un
sujet qui est extrêmement difficile dans
le domaine du nucléaire c'est que du
coup votre réacteur votre modèle de
réacteur n'a du sens que si vous le fait
acceptter à l'identique strictement à
l'identique par plusieurs autorités de
sûreté parce que si vous commencez à
avoir une version de votre tréacteur
pour la France une version de votre
trécteur pour la la Tchécoslovaquie la
Tchéquie une version de votre tréctour
pour la Suède et ceeter c'est fini
l'économie vous ne l'aurez pas parce que
vous ferez des modifications que vous ne
pouvez pas vous permettre déjà c'est un
handicap pour les gros d'avoir par
exemple duû modifier le Pr pour aller au
Royaume-Uni évidemment ça va pas dans le
sens de la compétitivité mais on peut à
la rigueur l'absorber sur un réacteur de
1700 MW surtout quand on en fait deux
mais sur un réacteur de 100 200 300 MW
on ne l'absorbera pas donc qu'est-ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui c'est quelque
chose de très nouveau c'est que alors
l'ASN est extrêmement motivée dans sur
ce sujet là et donc on a lancé en fait
un assessment européen de newward le SMR
de DF on a commencé avec trois autorités
de la France la République tchèque et la
Finlande aujourd'hui on en a si puisque
ces trois là sont associés la Suède la
Pologne et les Pays-Bas ce qui montre
d'ailleurs la motivation des pays au
passage et donc aujourd'hui on a si
autorités de sûreté qui sont ensemble en
train de faire l'assessment du réacteur
français avec l'idée que c'est le même
qu'ell vont valider à la fin et ça c'est
très très intéressant alors c'est très
délicat comme sujet parceidment si vous
prenez les exigences les plus élevé de
chacun bon à la fin ça fait un truc qui
décolle pas mais si tout tout le monde
se parle pour trouver les bons compromis
alors ça peut marcher et là pour le coup
voyez si vous a un réacteur qui est
validé à l'identique en France en
République tchèque en Finlande en Suède
en Pologne et au Pays-Bas on peut
imaginer qu'on peut faire une série
voilà on peut imaginer voilà et donc
c'est mais c'est vraiment là que ça se
joue c'est là que ça se joue voilà parce
que l'idée c'est que vous n'avez pas un
gros réacteur donc c'est pas toutes les
fonctions que vous mettez pour la sûreté
et cetera elles sont pas divisées par
1700 MW à la fin ça marche pas comme ça
l'économie marche pas comme ça elle
marche par le fait que votre réacteur
c'est un assemblage de modules
et vous faites une usine qui fabrique
les modules donc votre usine si elle
fabrique un module pas une usine si elle
fabrique vous faites une série de 30 et
qu'elle elle a fabriqué 4 ou 5 modules
pour le là ça commence à être une usine
voilà et donc c'est ça qui va faire
c'est ça qui fait l'économie donc on est
vraiment dans cette démarche de bon et
ce qui va faire l'arbitrage charbon
c'est le prix du CO2 aujourd'hui on a
quand même un petit sujet c'est que le
prix du CO2 est gentiment en train de
descendre ces derniers temps il est
passé pas loin de 100 € la tonne là il
est plutôt à 60 bon à 60 € la tonne vous
faites pas les mêmes choix
d'investissement qu'à 100 à 100 € la
tonne le le charbon il sort il sort de
la compétitivité par rapport au
nucléaire même même le neuf à 60 € comme
c'est moins risqué d'investir dans le
charbon ben vous investissez encore dans
le charbon c'est aussi bête que ça on a
vraiment un enjeu de politique publique
et internationale autour du autour du
prix du CO2 euh l'enjeu de l'eau est clé
alors ça il se trouve qu'avant d'avoir
ses responsabilités j'étais responsable
de la production hydroélectrique F donc
je suis très sensible à ces sujets là et
et c'est et c'est clair que pour
l'avenir c'est l'enjux clé c'est un des
enjux clés d'ailleurs on le voit premier
point tous nos sujets d'adaptation au
changement climatique euh ont c'est
l'eau le sujet le plus dimensionnant si
vous êtes en bord de mer c'est la
question de la hauteur à laquelle vous
placez le réacteur parce que quand même
il y a un sujet de montée des eau et si
vous êtes en bord de rivière c'est la
question de la variation du du débit et
de la température dans le cours d'eau et
de la la modification vous faites sur
températureau sachant qu'aujourd'hui il
y a deux grandes techniques vous prenez
l'eau vous refroidissez votre centrale
vous remettez l'eau dans le cours d'eau
avantage vous consommez pas d'eau du
tout mais vous la chauffez deuxième
technique vous prenez l'eau vous la
passe vous refroidissez vous l'envoyez
dans les tours là qui aéréfrigérante qui
fabrique des nuages alors vous ne
réchauffez pas le fleuve mais vous
consommez de l'eau alors on a tout un
programme de Red aujourd'hui sur des
aéroréfrigérants là com on les appelle
de nouvelles générations plus efficaces
qui vont recycler l'eau à l'inté ur pour
en consommer le moins possible renvoyer
un maximum à la rivière on a tout un
programme de RD là-dessus on fait aussi
beaucoup de de on regarde beaucoup tous
les systèmes de refroidissement qui ont
été utilisé dans d'autres industries que
le nucléaire parce que vous avez des
raffineries qui fonctionnent en plein
désert qui ont besoin de de voilà donc
on regarde tout ça simplement ça
consomme de l'énergie il y a pas de
mystère c'est-à-dire si vous consommez
moins d'eau pour refroidir c'est vous
faites des systèmes qui vont se
refroidir en partie avec l'air ou
autrement et vous allez consommer plus
d'énergie donc à la fin votre tréacteur
au lieu de sortir 1700 MW il en sortira
peut-être que 1500 parce qu' en fait on
en consommera 200 dans le
refroidissement vous voyez donc en fait
c'est toute une question d'arbitrage et
d'optimisation donc en gros aux endroits
où il y a assez d'eau pour tout le monde
bah faut faire un maximum de production
bord de mer et grand fleuve aux endroits
où faut arbitrer l'eau et la répartir
entre tout le monde il faut utiliser des
systèmes plus économes mais du coup vous
produisez moins d'électricité voilà
c'est et c'est cette choseel il faut
l'avoir à l'échelle nationale voilà euh
en analyse de cycle de vie donc la
question du béton alors on n pas plus de
béton dans le PR2 le PR1 on en a un
petit peu plus en fait on l'a fait plus
gros parce qu'il est plus facile à
construire plus gros ça c'est un détail
c'est c'est d'ordre de mais le fait
d'avoir une paroie épaisse ou de parois
ça rent même c'est même de grandeur
quand on regarde l'analyse du cycle de
vie du nucléaire en France c'est tout le
monde s'accorde pour dire il est tu 4 g
de CO2 par kilwh ce qui est très bas
c'est très très bas la moyenne mondale
est à 11 nous comme on recycle le
combustible en fait toujours pareil
parce que dans ces 4 g le plus important
c'est le cycle du combustible c'est la
mine d'uranium tout le cycle du
combustible
com part con
C
éidmentourexpériencection
je
finalement
Gén min question tout pasépu
plusieretéeurig à conruire
pas se le cacher donc pour ça donc c'est
pour ça parce qu'il est très exigeant au
niveau de sûreté enfin c'est ceux
d'entre vous qui n'ont jamais visité
flamandville avec plaisir on vous
accueillera vous verrez que on met en
service un objet industriel de très
grande taille flamandville T
flamandville 3 tout seul juste sur
l'alternatur flamandville 3 vous faites
plus que la consommation de Paris sur
une seule machine une seule machine
etess de qualité horlogerie
suisse que tout est à un niveau de
qualité incroyable vous êtes dans des
dimensions industrielles avec de la
précision d' Logerie c'est ça le sujet
il est très exigant à construire en
Chine ils l'ont construit mieux pourquoi
plus vite pourquoi d'abord ils l'ont
construit il y avait beaucoup d'équipes
françaises sur place he donc pour tout
le savoir-faire il l'avait quand même
comme ça mais surtout ils ont construit
les deux réacteurs de de Paes de Taishan
au milieu d'une série chinoise c'estd
que les entreprises qui ont construit
les réacteurs les les civilistes et les
gens qui ont fait les
montages avant de venir sur le chantier
de Taishan ils étaient sur un chantier
d'une autre centrale nucléaire chinoise
ils étaient pas dans autre chose donc en
fait eux ils l'ont fait dans leur courbe
enfin dans leur trajectoire
industrielle et en ce moment ils mettent
en service par an alors d'ailleurs c'est
à la gloire de la France ils mettent en
service par an un tout petit peu moins
qu ce qu'on mettait en service dans les
années 80 c'est bien ENF on fait pas la
même taille de pays quand ça montre la
performance qu' a eu la France dans les
années 80 quand même mais mais en
revanche ils sont partis pour en faire
beaucoup plus et et mais c'est dans leur
série
industrielle difficile à conduire en
revanche mis en service il fonctionne
d'entrée c'estàdire Tai Chan dès sa
première année de production a été le
réacteur nucléaire dans le monde quielle
produit le plus d'électricité dès sa
première année de production don ça
c'est quand même aussi à retenir
quandême difficile à construire mais il
marche il y a en effet un point de
retour d'expérience sur le
fonctionnement de du du cœur
nucléaire alors on a eu on a dû arrêé
tan à l'été 2021 parce qu'on avait vu
que des assemblages combustibles
c'est-à-dire des les les verticales
c'est un carré à peu près comme ceci là
dans lequel vous avez des crayons
combustibles qui sont dans la cuve on a
vu que il y avait quelques crayons
combustibles qui s'était mis à fuir or
tout l'uranium doit rester dans la gaine
du crayon combustible et pas partir dans
l'eau et s'était mis à fuir et donc
parce qu'ils avaient été agressés ils
avaient été agressés pourquoi parce que
nous avions en en bas de la de de ces
assemblages il y a des petits ressorts
qui tiennent assemblage combustible vous
avez des petits ressorts qui tiennent
les crayons dans lesquels il y a
l'uranium c'est comme des ressorts c'est
comme des suspensions de vieille de
vieill libousin américaines vous savez
c'est les ressort qui font comme ça là
et en fait il s'étaient corrodés et en
se corrodant il y en ait quelquesuns qui
s'étaient cassés et donc qu's avaient
ils avaient blessé en fait le crayon
combustible voilà et et et on a corrigé
la chose parce qu'il av ils avaient eu
un traitement thermique qui était
inadapté c'est pour ça qu'il
s'étaitcrodé d'ailleurs c'était à
nouveau un sujet de corrision sous
contrainte voilà on l'a corrigé et la
correction qui a été faite fait on a
plus le problème à taan et d'ailleurs
fait que la SN nous a dit avec cette
correction là à flamandville vous
démarrez flamandville je n'ai pas de
problème avec ça donc le sujet crayon
combustible assemblage combustible il
est réglé ensuite vous parliez de flu
hydraulique on aura un deuxième sujet à
régler
c'est que donc le Pr fonctionne
fonctionne bien l'eau qui circule dans
la cuve rentre en haut de la cuve elle
descend le long des parois de la cuve
autour d'un objet qui tient tous les
assemblages combustibles elle fait
demi-tour en bas elle remonte dans les
assemblages
combustibles faut imaginer ce que c'est
330° 155 bar l'eau remonte à 7 m second
dans les assemblages combustibles sous
155 fois la pression atmosphérique à 300
de une belle cte minute hein
euh on voit des sujets où on peut
optimiser ce flux parce que ce flux est
légèrement ENF il y a des petits détails
dans le flux qui font qu'il y a des
petites vibrations des assemblages
combustibles qui posent aucun problème
de sûreté mais on peut optimiser le
dispositif qui en flux cuve à l'endroit
où l'ARE fait demi-tour pour que le flux
soit encore meilleur on le fera l'ASN
est d'accord avec nous que c'est pas un
sujet à traiter tout de suite c'est un
sujet à traiter sur la durée de vie de
l'installation donc le problème de taan
il est il est nominal et donc maintenant
le cœur du réacteur est validé ça c'est
point très important euh
PR1 par rapport à
PR2 c'est les mêmes fondamentalement
c'est le même niveau de sûreté on a fait
une chose pour simplifier c'est que sur
le PR1 il y a il y avait plein de
dispositions qui étaient prévu pour que
vous puissiez ple faire plein de choses
en en service c'est-à-dire voilà vous
vous aviez pendant que le réacteur
fonctionnait un système de sûreté en
plus qui preneit la main vous pouviez
aller faire la maintenance des autres
systèmes de sûreté pendant ce temps bon
on a estimé que contte tenu de nos
pratiques de maintenance en en France il
vaait mieux qu'on économise cette chose
là et qu'on fasse un petit peu moins de
maintenance en marche c'est un compromis
économique qu'on a fait oui c'était
aussi allement à l'origine mais peu
importe c'est et donc on a un système de
moins mais en fait le système qui était
en plus il servait à faire de la
maintenance en service qu'on fera pas
donc en fait ça veut dire qu'on a le
même on a le même niveau de même niveau
de sûreté on fait de la modulation de
manière
analogue on est à peu près dans les
mêmes niveaux de de modulation que le
parc existant pendant les études de
conception on a fait un exercice un
petit peu différent mais qui conduit à
peu près au même résultat c'est-à-dire
on s'est dit dans la France des années
2040 il va y avoir normalement beaucoup
de solaire beaucoup d'éolien comment c
ce solaire et cet éolien fluctue dans la
journée et on a calculé la modulation de
le PR2 pour qu'il compense des
fluctuations de solaire et d'éolien dans
la journée en moyenne enfin qu'il soit
capable d'absorber ça on l'a dimensionné
plutôt comme ça que pour s'adapter à la
conso voz c'est plutôt épouser les
courbes de charges de solaire et à la
fin ça fait à peu près les mêmes
caractéristiques de modulation qu'un
réacteur qui a actuellement sur le parc
et c'est très performant ça veut dire
qu'un PR2 qui fonctionne à 1700 MW vous
pouvez le descendre jusqu'à 300 250 MW
en le gardant en service vous voyez puis
le remonter tout ça dans des zones de 1
demiheure une heure hein on est un peu
les seuls à faire ça quand même he donc
mais aussi on fait ça parce qu'on a 75 %
de lucléire ceux qui ont 10 % de
nucléaire leur nucléaire il fonctionne
toujours à fond nous quand c'est 75 % on
est obligé de de fluctuer voilà et puis
monsieur ça par rapport à la la notion
de modulation euh est-ce qu'il est
envisageable euh à terme que les les les
SMR en tout cas ces ces technologies euh
nucléaires là euh permettent
euh de répondre à à à la pointe sur
l'ensemble de la production nationale
c'estàdire que la la la la centrale
marginale soit un jour une une une
centrale nucléaire de type SMR ou Amr
est-ce que est-ce que ça c'est
envisageable je je je vais pas dire non
parce qu'on par hypothèse parce qu'on
sait pas de quoi l'avenir est fait mais
mais c'est quand même pas pour ça que
c'est conçu
c'est c'est quand même des objets qui
sont conçus pour fonctionner un grand
nombre d'heures dans l'année et
éventuellement pour pour fluctuer mais
c'est pas des installations qui sont
conçues pour démarrer aux extrêmes dans
l'année c'est quand même pas vraiment
fait pour ça c'est pas
l'espritur parle SMR Amr Amr alors c'est
pour ça que je disais je vais pas
m'engager sur les Amr parce que là ça
peut dépendre de leur de leur
technologie on est pas là on en est pas
vraiment là c'estàd que une réaction
nucléaire c'est pas non plus très bon de
la démarrer de l'arrêter de la baisser
de la baisser de la remonter c'est déjà
voz par exemple vous savez quand on on
charge le réacteur on part pour un cycle
de fonctionnement qui est qui est de 12
ou de ou de 18 mois sur le Pr ça sera 18
mois vous pouvez beaucoup plus moduler
en début de cycle qu'en fin de cycle
parce qu'il y a plein de phénomènes
physique physique nucléaair pour le coup
qui se joue quand vous modulez vous vous
dégradez plus vite votre la la le
rendement de votre réaction nucléaire et
vous pouvez plus le faire en début qu'en
fin de cycle donc pour le moment je
dirais est le faire massivement c'est
pas évident quoi et alors s' vaut par
rapport à
flamandville et alors je suis d'accord
avec vous les chiffres sont trompeurs
quand vous faites quand vous réalisez un
aménagement nucléaire vous avez trois
grandes phases en fait je suis un peu
caricatural mais pour résumer et le
chemin critique qui tient en trois
phases vous avez une phase vous faites
le génie civil le béton c'est c'est
pendant un temps c'est là-dessus que se
joue le planning il faut construire les
bâtiments en particulier ceux de l'inon
nucléaire voilà deuxième temps vous
remplissez ce que vous avez constru
c'està-dire vous venez installer les
équipements vous installez tous vos
tuyaux tous vos tous vos câbles et
cetera c'est d'ailleurs cette phase là
qui est la plus sensible et la plus à
industrialisé quand on va faire la série
parce que le génie civil finalement avec
les qu'on a construit je pense que
maintenant on on est pas mal et même sur
in cl point où on a dû annoncer un
retard l'essentiel du retard du génie
civil il est dû au covid on a quand même
pris le covid de plein fouet hein les
confinements au Royaume-Uni en plein au
moment où vous aviez 5000 personnes sur
le chantier de gé civil à un moment vous
passez de 5000 à zéro forcément ça a un
petit impact sur le planning euh mais
l'essentiel du retard qu'on a pris sur
le génie civil c'est le covid plus 6
mois normalement on peut dire quand même
que voilà j civil commence ê mer le gros
enjeu maintenant c'est tout le travail
des électriciens des mécaniciens qui
viennent installer les choses dans le
dans le et là vous avez plein de corps
de métier qu'il faut coordonner c'est là
le gros enjeu vous arriver à coordonner
des corps de métier extrêmement
différent c'est la deuxème étape la
troisème étape c'est la mise en service
vous faites tous vos essais puis vous
montez en puissance et ces trois
compétences très différent c'est quand
vous êtes en phase de montage vous êtes
moins en moins g civilist quand vous
êtes en phase d'ESS vous avez plus les
autres donc ce qu'il faut comparer c'est
les mêmes phases et là cette fois c'est
plus 5 ans c'est 15 ou c'est 15 ou 18
ans c'est-à-dire entre le début de
sttivau et le début de flamandville il y
a 16
ans et donc c'est là que je disais il y
a la génération euh il commence à avoir
l'effet générationnel dont je parlais
tout à l'heure voilà c'est pour ça qu'il
faut
enchaîner d'autres
questionsrê on en reste là en vous
remerciant pour cet échange merci
beaucoup merci
beaucoup simplement pour préciser on
vous allez avoir des questionnaires he
pour avoir un certain nombre
d'information parce qu'il y a des choses
que vous voulez pas nous donner mais on
va quand même revenir par fenêtre
euh et euh et donc voilà il il y aura
des informations complémentaires et et
et si vous pouvez nous apporter ce que
ce qu'on a appelé l'effet falaise mais
enfin bon peut-être pas l'ffet falaise
mais la persective 40 60 80 voilà ça
sera ça sera très bien question monsur
monsieur le rapporteur je me permet de
de de vous dire que nous préparons
conformément au terme de la loi je crois
que c'est dans la loi accélération des
procédures que vous avez demandé ça le
Parlement nous préparons un rapport au
gouvernement nous préparons un rapport
au Gouvernement au Parlement pardon un
rapport du Gouvernement au Parlement
excusez-moi que nous allons sortir au
mois de au mois de mars plus tard et et
qui donc va va tenter d'apporter des
réponses complémentaires au questions
que vous venez de poser he ça nous vous
devons quand je dis nous en tant que en
tant qu'administration nous vous devons
effectivement ce rapport du gouvernement
mois de mars prochain ça sera
pasusivé ah benah écoutez si vous voulez
avoir une exclusivité il y a pas de
problème on pourra on pourra on pourra
organiser ça sans problèmez ce qu'on
souhaite la
transparence
so